- So my son's left cookies and milk,
on his bedside table.
How do I tell him that
Santa is lactose intolerant?
(laughing)
- So do I just drink the milk
and take the shits for my son?
- Well...
- Do I leave it there
and break his heart?
- I remember one time my dad was like,
"No no, no Connor, Santa likes beer."
(laughing)
(upbeat music)
- Hello and welcome to
another episode of TrashTaste.
I am your host for today, Gigguk
and with me, are the usual boys.
And today we have a very
special guest with us.
No one,
(laughing)
it's just me today, I finally...
(palm thudding)
- I thought you're about to be like,
"We have a very special
guest, me by myself."
- It's Gigguk,
The Anime Zone and Steve Handjobs.
(Joey laughing)
Who is, been left at home today.
But, yeah.
- Maybe you did wear a turtle neck.
- I did not know wear turtle neck today.
- In the Christmas spirit,
I brought you guys gifts.
- You can get me any.
- Oh.
- Can't believe it.
- Yes, so this is apparently,
gonna be our Christmas special.
- It's not.
(Garnt chuckling)
- This is a Christmas special.
- This is our Christmas special
that we are not recording.
- You wrapped it up and everything.
- Holy shit.
You actually wrapped it up.
- Yeah, sure.
- What the fuck man.
- I wrapped it up.
- By the way, Merry Christmas,
'cause I think this should be
airing on Boxing Day, right?
- Yeah.
- Do Americans have Boxing Day?
Meilyne, do Americans have Boxing Day?
- [Meilyne] What do you mean Boxing?
- Okay, no they don't have boxing day.
- Boxing day is the day
after Christmas Day.
- Yeah.
- [Meilyne] It's not
anime so I don't know.
- Okay, that's true.
(thuds)
So they maybe riding on the on the thing,
- [Both] Right.
- So, the box is fine,
so you can open it up.
- [Both] Right.
- But they maybe writing
on the thing in Japanese.
Joey, ignore it don't read it, just.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Okay, I wanna look at the box.
- Okay, so you can, just open the box now
but when inside, I think
they'll be a label on it.
Just don't read the label, Joey.
- Okay.
- Garnt it might be in kanji.
- So you should...
- Okay, well,
I can't read anyway.
- Just rip it open.
- So I'm all good.
(Joey shrieking)
- Yeah, to explain what Boxing Day is,
isn't Boxing Day,
the actual day you're meant
to open your presents?
- I don't fucking know.
- Isn't that why it's called Boxing Day?
- Is that what it is called?
- Yeah, I think that's why
it's called Boxing Day.
- It was just the day you
ate all the leftovers.
(Garnt chuckling)
- I was told Boxing Day was like an event,
where everyone boxes it out.
- Oh, it's a little music box.
- So don't open yours yet, right?
- Okay.
- Don't, you might wanna
play it up to the microphone.
- Okay.
- Everyone needs to be silent.
(music box winding)
- Let me play this.
- Guess the song.
- Yeah, guess the song.
(bell chiming)
- Is this your name?
(Garnt chuckling)
Yes. Oh my god, thank you so much.
(Connor chuckling)
Where did you get this?
- I think I know exactly
where he got this from.
All right, I'm not gonna look
at the look at the label.
- Yeah, don't look at the labels Joey.
(music box winding)
I got Joey something too.
- All right, I have to
wait for yours to shut up.
(Joey chuckling)
- Wait, wait, let's
night call Zenzenzense.
(bell chiming)
(Garnt chuckling)
- Oh yeah, that just stops it.
- Huh!
- I think it just stops it.
(bell chiming)
- [Meilyne] I can't hear it.
- I can hear it.
- Oh,
(singing in foreign language)
that one right.
Fucking, that's also your name, right?
- It's the same band, right?
- Yeah, it's Radwimps.
- Yeah.
- I think it's the ending,
- 'Cause Joey always sings
this song in karaoke.
- Yeah, so it's a...
- I don't sing this one in karaoke.
- Do you know what I fucking did?
- No, no, I sing a fucking,
I sing Zenzenzense mostly.
- Zenzenzense and the one
from, Weathering with You.
- Yeah, Weathering with You.
I like this song as well.
- We have a bunch of musical boxes.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Yay.
- I don't know if you can
hear in the background,
but it's just going on now,
I shouldn't have winded it so much.
- [Meilyne] Boxing day is
the day after Christmas.
- Yeah.
- [Meilyne] And you can (indistinct)
- So yeah, Boxing Day
the day after Christmas.
(Joey chuckling)
Did you have boxing day in Australia?
- Yeah, we do.
(laughing)
- It's just so...
I don't know if the mic is picking that-
It is loud as fuck in this room right now.
I think I know exactly
what you got in this box.
- Yeah.
- Because I bought one as well.
- Oh, did you?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I like Ghibli ones as well.
- 'Cause your anime songs, and I was like,
I should buy anime songs for the boys.
- I got one actually which was
like a Vulpix from Pokemon.
- I saw that.
- Right.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, that one's really cute.
- This is an awesome gift though.
- [Connor] Yeah there you go..
- I could easily give
this to all my friends.
- You're welcome boys, thanks for my gift.
- Thank you very much.
(Connor chuckling)
- I'll get you a present soon don't worry.
(laughing)
- It's not like we literally just decided
this was the Christmas
episode, the day of recording.
- Yeah, we didn't know this was gonna
be the Christmas episode.
- I just thought I'd bring
a gift, I'll be nice.
Wow it's really going on.
- It's just fucking going.
It just keeps going, doesn't it?
- Meilyne, do you wanna have this for now?
- Yeah, do you wanna hold on to this?
Just get it off screen.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- [Meilyne] Okay, I'll
just put it outside.
- Put on my desk,
- Yeah it's fine.
- Just put on my desk it should be fine.
- Yeah but..
- It will turn off naturally,
don't turn it anymore.
(chuckling)
- Yeah, just leave it, just leave it.
(laughs)
Just let it sit on the
desk it will be fine.
Yeah, but I know exactly
where you got those from
because you took a trip, didn't you?
- I did, I went up to
Hokkaido, but it's all good.
You should chill a little vacation.
- Yeah.
- Just relaxing, it's nice.
- Every YouTuber needs a
vacation every now and again.
- Yeah, and just eat all their
food, food's amazing there.
- I told you they've
optimized the food, right?
- It's good, man, it's good.
(Joey chuckling)
It's as good as everyone says it is.
You should go.
- Yeah.
- Go if you get the chance.
- What are some like, specific
dishes that you had up there,
that you would recommend to
people who wanna go to Hokkaido?
- Anything with milk in
it is just like the best.
- Yeah.
- Does it meet the hype?
- 'Cause I've heard so
much about Hokkaido milk
and what is so good about the milk there?
- It's like the breed of cow...
- I don't know it's rich, it's real rich.
- It's like full cream.
- [Garnt] Right.
- And I had like a milk ice cream.
I don't normally like milk ice cream,
but it was just like,
intense milk hit you.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
(Connor sighing)
(Joey chuckling)
- I saw you posted a picture
of beer ice cream as well.
- Oh yeah.
- [Connor] That's like...
- Just to prove that Japan does
every flavor of self serve.
I don't know why you'd
ever want beer ice cream.
- Yeah, there was like ice
cream, that was just beer
and I was like, I mean sure, I'll try it.
I like both these things individually.
- Even alcoholics will like that one.
(laughing)
Yeah this will be good.
- It tastes like shit.
- I can't imagine a beer flavored
anything aside from beer,
and it tastes...
- It's just like a musky ice cream.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- What's the weirdest
flavor ice cream you've had?
- Rum ray, am joking.
(laughing)
- How dare you? Probably the beer right?
- Probably the beer right.
I've normally, I don't know.
- I've had fish ice cream before.
- Oh,
- What, where, Japan?
- In Japan.
- Oh, that sounds disgusting.
- Yeah, it was like a salmon ice cream.
(Garnt exclaiming)
Yeah.
- They do that shit here with food.
They're like, I don't
care about the boundaries.
I like both these things
let's make it into food.
- That's like the equivalent of fucking,
what some Americans do,
which is like buying of McFlurry
and then just dipping it with fries.
- Okay, but I...
- Which just blows my mind.
- Okay, but actually I kind of like that.
- No, no.
- Why?
- What?
- It's pretty good.
- I went to, fucking Oki took
me to a Steak n Shake once,
which is where like, the optimal
place of where you do that.
And I just saw like six
Americans dipping their fries
into the shakes, I'm just like, I can't.
I can't be here, I have to leave.
- We're living in a
first world country dude.
(Joey chuckling)
Why are you eating like this?
- Honestly, like, I don't do it often
but it tasted pretty
good when I've done it.
- I don't get it, it's like a nice,
it's the synergy of the
saltiness of the fries
and the sweetness of
the shakes, I'm like no.
- I don't understand why it
works, it just does, right?
- It doesn't though.
- Also Steak n Shakes,
there the most depressing
place in America.
(Joey chuckling)
I went to one at midnight,
'cause I was like, yeah...
- Maybe because you went at midnight.
(Garnt chuckling)
- There was $1.50 burgers.
- Yeah.
- I was just like, Jesus Christ.
- I don't know, you've never
been to a White Castle before.
That's true depression.
- Okay...
- I've never been to
a White Castle before.
Does it meet the hype?
- White Castle, the hype of what?
- I don't know,
'cause I only know White Castle
because of that one movie,
- Right.
- What's it? Harold and
Kumar or something like that.
- Oh yeah.
- And...
- So, White Castle doesn't sell
burgers, they sell sliders.
- Okay.
- Right, so it's like the tiny buggers.
- What's the difference
between a burger and a slider.
- It's like a mini burger, right?
- A slider is just like a
mini burger, apparently.
- Right.
- I don't know where it comes from.
But basically they sell
sliders instead of burgers.
- Right.
- But like normally, right,
like when you buy a slider,
you go to some American restaurants.
And I like meat, like my
chicken Parmesan sliders,
that shit's bomb...
- They don't say it like that,
- What?
(Garnt chuckling)
- Parmesan,
- Parmesan sliders.
- Oh, what do you say?
- It's the way you added that-
- Chicken Parmesan sliders.
- Parmesan.
- I just call it Parmesan, right?
- Parmesan?
- Parmesan yeah, Parmesan.
- Oh dude,
that hurts me hearing that.
- British man's language.
Alright go ahead then.
- Anyway, that chicken,
my favorites are chicken
Parmesan sliders right.
So it's like the chicken Parmesan,
then you put like some lettuce in it.
It's fucking nice,
but White Castle slider is
literally just two soggy buns,
and the thinnest patty in existence.
- Yeah.
(Garnt chuckling)
- It's like paper thin patties.
- It's pathetic.
- Oh God.
- So you can get like a six pack of...
- Six pack of sliders.
(laughing)
- Yeah, it's like a six,
they box it like a six pack of
sliders for $4 or something,
I'm just like, "This is true depression."
- All I know is that everyone
I know who goes there,
has like the shits afterwards.
- Oh yeah.
- Which is like...
(laughing)
to me that's like,
how on earth we've got to the point
where that's just an acceptable outcome.
- How is it that Americans have gauged
the tastiness of a fast food joint,
by how much this stomach is
just destroyed the next day?
- You know what...
- People are like,
"Oh, yeah it's not a good chili's meal,
unless I'm shitting myself
constantly the next day."
- But I feel the same with Indian though.
I have to destroy the toilets.
- Sure.
- After I eat Indian,
so I can kind of get it,
but at the same time,
I can only do it, like at
most once every few weeks.
- But like a burger shouldn't do that.
(laughing)
A burger shouldn't...
like Indian, I've always
accepted the Indian does that.
- Yeah, because of the spices right?
- It's all the spices,
but it's just like bread and meat,
what is happening?
(laughing)
What went wrong?
- It's the oil.
- Okay, you know,
also the most egregious
thing that I hear they do,
is that they put the grease
on top of the burgers.
That's disgusting.
- Yeah.
- Who did this? And who likes it?
Because I remember I
went to Steak n Shake,
and they did this to my
burger, and I was like,
"Well, I don't want this anymore.
Why would you do this?"
- Yeah.
- "It's like you took the
worst part of the meat,
which is the part that
makes you feel sick."
- Have you...
- "And you put it on top, why?"
- I remember when I
was staying at Sydney's
family's house in Wisconsin.
- [Connor] Yeah.
And they got a takeaway
pizza joint one day.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- And one of the big selling points
of this takeaway pizza joint,
is they had garlic bread.
And the selling point, was that
if you put a wet paper towel
on the garlic bread,
it would literally soak it in oil.
(Joey laughing)
And they were hyping this up to be like,
"Yo, if you put that, if
there's so much oil on this."
That if you put the wet
paper towel, it will soak it,
and it will become completely wet.
And I'm just thinking, "How
is this a selling point?
Why would I want to eat this?"
- It's like that Simpsons episode,
when Homer is trying to get so fat
that he gets the disability like being,
- Oh yeah.
- And Dr Nick's like,
"Grab the burger,
rub it against the piece
of paper' (chuckling)
and then go, see through, you can eat it."
- I thought it was like a joke.
I thought it was satire,
- [Joey] Yeah.
- But no, they literally,
like market it there, as
this garlic bread is so oily,
that you can literally soak up
an entire paper towel,
- That's disgusting.
- And I just think about
it and I'm just like,
I hold it in my hands and
it was literally dripping
and I took one bite,
- That's..
- And one bite was enough for me.
- That's like the pure survival food
'cause the sheer amount of
oil, could power a lamp,
for like decades.
- Have you ever heard of
this American burger joint
called the Heart Attack Grill?
- Yeah, of course.
- Yeah.
- The fucking... I was
watching a video yesterday,
of this guy who ate the
the biggest one there
which is called the
quadruple bypass burger,
- Right.
- And it's literally think of a Big Mac,
but stack six big macs on top,
- Yeah, I've seen it,
it's ridiculous.
- And it was like, I already thought that,
it's like 20,000 calories as well.
This guy demolishes it in five minutes.
I don't know how the fuck he did it.
But the part that got me
was, he was like alright,
we're getting to the bun
now, the bun by the way,
is soaked in lard.
I'm like,
- [Garnt] Oh, disgusting.
- "You shouldn't..."
- That's so veil.
- No, no, no.
"A piece of bread should
not be soaked in anything."
- Nothing should be soaked
in pure fucking fat.
- Yeah, also the fries were
oiled in pure lard as well.
- That's disgusting.
(Garnt chuckling)
I just...
- And you get a shake on top of that.
- I don't understand the appeal of that.
That's just ridiculous.
- It just sounds gross. It looked gross.
It looked like something
out of the alien movies
- Yeah, why..
- I didn't wanna put that in my stomach.
- Why do people hate their bodies?
Like...
(chuckling)
- There's only like
some, let's say cuisines
you can only enjoy when you
want to destroy your body.
And that's probably,
like at 3:00am,
- Yeah.
- After like...
- After five guys.
(Joey chuckling)
- After five guys or like,
I can never eat a kebab sober,
like something has got...
(Joey chuckling)
something has gone wrong with me.
Like something has gone
wrong with my life.
If I'm eating a kebab,
and I'm completely sober.
- You know I'm hella depressed,
when I'm eating a kebab for lunch.
(laughing)
- I love a great burger
with a bit of grease on it
a little bit.
- [Garnt] Just a little bit.
(crosstalk)
But there's a clear line, that
no even drunk me would pass.
And the Heart Attack
Grill to me is just like,
there is no reason why
I would wanna come here,
other than to feel healthy.
(Joey chuckling)
Like and just look and be like damn.
- Because any meal you have after,
going to the Heart Attack Grill.
You'll be like damn,
- But also you just stay there
you see the other
patreons and you're like,
"Oh, I'm doing pretty good for myself."
"Hey, like damn, okay.
Maybe I am in shape."
- Because I think the selling point
of the Heart Attack Grill
is that, first of all,
like, when you walk in,
they put on like a hospital gown on you.
And they sit you in a
wheelchair, to wheel you in.
And here's the kicker, if
you weigh over 300 pounds,
you get the meal for free.
- I feel like it should be the opposite.
You should be like, it's
like taxing the rich right?
(Joey chuckling)
If you're already fat, you
should be charging at least,
(Joey chuckling)
[Both] Double.
- To force you to maintain,
this egregious weight.
- I feel like the concept
of Heart Attack Grill,
it's just kind of like, if you you hear it
and you're like, this
is like fiction, right?
This is from like some dystopian society.
- Yeah, this is from
like some George Orwell.
(laughing)
So this is how they fatten you
up, before they dispose you.
- You know when we watch this
like 500 pounds life videos.
- Oh, 600 pounds life
- That one whatever, you watch it,
and you realize that most of
these people just have trauma.
Like at what point do we start like...
Okay, maybe it's not trauma,
if he's walking into
the Heart Attack Grill.
(Garnt and Joey chuckling)
Maybe that's on him.
(Joey and Garnt chuckling)
You know what I mean,
I think that there's going
beyond a point of comfort food
and there's gonna be like,
this is just his fault.
Because this shows,
these videos with these 600 pound people,
do you really fucking good job
at making you feel sorry
for them and be like,
"Yo' man, okay yeah, like
his parent died at five.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- Yeah, eating disorder.
- For some reason, at the age of five,
his mama is taking him to
the Heart attack Grill,
and that's the only way
that she can remember him.
And it's like,
"Okay, I get it."
(Garnt chuckling)
"I sympathize with you, but should you?"
(both chuckling)
'Cause it's like, what
if my parents were like,
It's all have had since the age of 10."
would I be doing crack
would I be doing crack,
but it's just comfort.
(Joey chuckling)
- It's comfort food.
- To me, it's like, there's a clear limit,
to the point where you're gonna be like,
alright, well, maybe I should
stop feeling sorry for you.
- Yeah.
- That's just...
- Oh no, I never watch those
shows that like feel sorry.
- Well 'cause I've noticed I watched them
and they do a really
good job making you think
damn, like I guess,
that could be me.
- Yeah they set up,
that's the thing, they
set it up as a sob story.
- Yeah.
- But what you're seeing
and what you're hearing is
the complete opposite.
- [Garnt] Two different things.
- Two entirely different things.
- Well I think, as so many
wished, a little chubbier,
not knowing in that level.
(chuckling)
Like I get it, I get
how you can gain weight.
But there's like a limit.
- Yeah.
- Of where I think, that it
would go beyond anything.
- Like some of these that, you dint like,
I don't know like fucking
15 hotdogs in the morning
with cheese and chili on it.
- Yeah.
- I think I would draw the line,
I think I can't (chuckling)
- Right yeah, but that's the thing...
The thing that surprises me more
is not the fact that there's,
like complaining about having
all this weight problems
and then they proceed to eat
a whole fucking box of chilies
right?
- Yeah.
- But it's also just the egregious amount
of food that they can somehow stomach.
I'm like, it just looking
at it makes my stomach hurt.
- It just doesn't make sense to me
and I feel like you must have
like, just grown up with this
and because, every time I go to America,
I always like the food portions in there.
We've talked about this
before, are massive then.
I'm forced to have to, have
these massive food portions
and like the first week, fucking great.
After a week of staying in America.
- I wanna go home.
(chuckling)
- I'm like, is that salad?
And I ask for the salad,
and what comes out is a fucking forest.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
This aint a fucking salad.
- It's like six heads of lettuce.
(Garnt laughing)
- The amount of dressing is
like the same as the meal,
its like 1600 calories.
- So, what of like a fucking rabbit.
- I'm like did you deforest
the entire Amazon rainforest
just to put on my plate like this.
(Joey chuckling)
This is the kind of like free portions
we're talking about here.
- This sucks man, 'cause
it's such, it's so unfair.
Because if you get fat in Japan,
I feel like that's on you.
- [Joey and Garnt] Yeah.
- But if you get fat
in America, it's like,
everything was set up against you.
- Welcome to the system.
- Everything was set up to make you fat.
- Yeah.
- So it's like how the fuck,
it's not fair, which is why...
- 'Cause like my diet in America is awful,
obviously 'cause of the food there.
- I keep saying whenever I go there.
- But also, I get to the point
where I want to have something,
but something not greasy,
and especially like in the
Midwest, where it's like,
the countryside, there's a lot less choice
and a lot less healthy choices as well.
So, you're kind of forced to be like,
"Hey, you can have, to cook for yourself."
And if you can't cook for yourself
then you're pretty much fucked.
- [Joey And Connor] Yeah.
- And that's why,
its so much harder to
eat healthy over there
than is, say like in Japan.
- But even then in America,
I remember I went to the...
to Walmart, and I was like, okay,
lets get some healthy foods,
And it was really hard
to find the actual stuff.
- Yeah.
The actual healthy stuff.
And then I go to the next
aisle, there's a whole aisle,
this blew my mind, of hotdogs,
a whole aisle of hotdogs,
not sausages, hotdogs.
And I was like this is insane,
I thought there was
only one type of hotdog.
(Joey chuckling)
I didn't realize that hotdogs,
were any different from each other,
'cause they all taste the same.
Hotdogs never taste any different.
- Yeah.
- Do you ever notice,
when you go to your
friend's barbecue, whatever,
and they give you a hotdog,
have you ever been like wow,
this tastes different from my hot dog?
- No.
- No it's always like,
I put mustard on that,
but that's how you differentiate it.
- Yeah.
- They all taste the fucking same.
- I mean, it's all the different brands.
- Yeah, and somehow they had like 10 rows
on a whole aisle of hotdogs.
I was blown away, I was
like this is insane.
- I think like there is difference,
in sometimes it's filled with cheese
and sometimes...
- That's vile. Don't do that.
I don't want-
- Really?
No I like that.
- No, no because...
- No, because this is American
cheese we're talking about.
Like that's a real cheese.
If it was filled with
actual like real cheese,
then yeah, I'd be a little open to it.
- And I'm pissed off they've managed
to infiltrate Japan somehow,
'cause whenever you get anything
with cheese on top of it here,
its such a gamble, whether
its American, like fucking...
- Plastic cheese, yeah.
- Fucking Americans.
- See this is the advantage of not putting
condiments and everything.
I can actually-
- Fuck off
- Taste the fucking difference
between a normal hot dog
and the cheese hot dog
and like...
- Because that's an important
life skill, isn't it?
(all laughing)
- Yes, I know I can't differentiate
between 10 different brands of hot dogs.
- Because otherwise that's life,
you just put condiments
on it all the time,
then it just tastes like
the condiments, right.
You don't get to taste the
softies and the difference.
- Again its this energy.
- What do you think we are fucking
drowning out hotdogs and sauce.
- Honestly, it looks kind of
looks like a lot of the times.
- Jesus Christ.
(Garnt chuckling)
- If I gave you five
brands of generic hotdogs,
would you be able to tell the difference
between any of them?
'Cause I wouldn't be able to.
- I mean.
- That just sounds like,
a Trash Taste special.
(all laughing)
- I'm not that big of a fan of
hotdogs, but I mean I can...
- What is like a food like,
if we gave you different types of it,
that you'd be able to differentiate?
(Garnt exclaiming)
- [Myelin] Not tap water.
- Not tap water.
- Tap water.
- I can differentiate between tap water
and normal water, but not like say.
- Everyone can.
- Not say like Voss water.
I don't understand Voss water.
- What the fuck is Voss water?
- Have you never heard had of Voss water?
- No.
- It's like the..
really, really posh water
that comes in a glass bottle.
You can see it on screen now,
and it's only at like-
- It's ridiculous.
- Really high class hotels.
- And I've sampled one before,
I remember 'cause it was like,
I was really, really thirsty
and it was the only water available,
and it just taste like water.
- There is no difference
between the bottled water brands
I'm convinced, and when
you watch how they,
half of it comes from
the same fucking place,
which is just the normal taps,
that all the people are using in the area.
- Oh, dude you know what's
the one type of person
that I'll never be friends with?
When someone will take a sip of water
and being like,
"Oh, this is hard water, can
I get some soft water please?"
People like that... I know
people like that in California,
- I knew someone who could
only drink a brand of,
I can't remember which brand.
- [Both] Evian.
(Joey chuckling)
- Literally refused to
use any other water,
and if they used bottled water,
like in like cup noodles,
had to be bottled Evian.
Can you believe this.
(chuckling)
- But I don't know man,
I don't like tap water.
- Whatever.
- I have gone through a phase where...
- I have got one million views on YouTube
and then this is what happens,
(Garnt chuckling)
he's like 'Only Evian on me'.
(Connor chuckling)
- Well I mean because is tap
water drinkable in the UK?
- [Both] Yeah.
- It's drinkable in the UK.
- [Joey] Right.
- Where I live,
I've grown up where every where in my life
tap water is sucked.
- Right.
- And I've heard about this
mythical good tap water
that people talk about some of the times,
Connor is one of those people.
- Come to Australia bro,
we have great top water.
- I've always had like, shitty tap water,
- It depends, 'cause if
you get it from a quality
that's like-
- Like this, to me this
clearly tastes like tap water,
'cause if I can taste
the sink in tap water,
its like inferior water fro me,
I don't wanna taste something metallic.
I don't wanna... sometimes
I get the hard water thing,
'cause sometimes I drink
tap water and I'm like,
I feel even more dehydrated-
- I'd like a little picture.
(Joey chuckling)
- Than when when I first drank this water.
This video is sponsored
by Raid Shadow Legends.
- Raid.
- [Joey] Badass champions, tough bosses,
millions of players.
- Do you like fighting noble
kings and dark wizards?
- I do.
- Joey you're in luck
because Raid has all of that for you.
You will uncover prophecies,
curses, betrayals
and my childhood friend.
- Raid.
- Raid Shadow Legends.
- So use my links below
to download Raid yourself
to your mobile phone or PC.
- Raid, Raid.
- Now I don't wanna be on
the topic of Raid's boys,
but what is that tree
doing raiding our cell.
(all exclaiming)
- Who are those three champions
next to the tree gentlemen?
- Is that sir Nicholas
Reinbeast and Frostbringer?
Now presently gentlemen,
my favorite thing about
Raid Shadow Legends.
- [Both] Raid.
- Raid, is that it plays itself,
it has an auto mode.
So if there's some missions
that are too grindy,
you can just let the game play it.
And did you know that
you can summon champions
at the tavern gentlemen?
- [Joey] How many champions?
- As many as you want Joey.
- [Joey] Really?
- So what's new in Raid?
Well, let me tell you this month,
Raid just released their
biggest ever update, in Raid.
- I have heard the main
event is Doom Tower God,
is that true?
Is it a tower with 120 floors.
- I could barely contain my excitement.
- [Garnt] A bunch of
secret challenge rooms
and 12 seriously badass bosses
that you have to take on.
(Joey shrieking)
- I cannot wait to Raid
Shadow Legends those bosses.
- [Joey] Raid.
- On top of that they are also releasing
14 awesome new champions
just in time for the holidays
along with a whole host of
holiday events and tournaments.
- [Connor] There's never really been,
a better time to start playing,
and here's the best part,
the Raid team are giving away
a bunch of new free goodies.
- Oh, my god.
- No way.
- [Joey] Oh, my god.
- [Garnt] No way.
- Plus gentlemen calm down,
don't get your chops up yet.
Plus a super special champion
to help get everyone started
in the tower, Bulwark.
- [Garnt] And not only that,
50 gems in XP boosters,
some energy refills and
even an ancient chart
as soon as you get in game,
you can get my account
here on screen right now.
So if you wanna go in and
even join my clan perhaps,
(chuckling)
go ahead gamers.
And its just that easy.
Gentleman, all you got to do is,
click that link in the
description down below
or as I like to say raid
that link in the description
(Joey and Garnt laughing)
I'll see you gamers inside.
- Thank you,
- Thank you, to Raid for
sponsoring this video.
I feel like the best time to judge
how good water is, is
when you're hung over.
'Cause when I'm hung over,
there are definitely different levels,
(Connor chuckling)
I feel different levels of
hydration when I'm hangover.
'cause I need, when
you're feeling like shits
and you want to feel re hydration again
that's when like,
I will stick by the bottled
water every time over tap water.
I mean I will take tap water...
- Dude, I just drink a liter
of whatever is near me.
- Oh dude, if I'm like,
depending on how hungover I am,
I'll fucking drink a
liter of toilet water,
anything to just get something
like fucking fluid in me.
- Yeah, what do you mean?
- Yeah, I know that's what I'm saying.
(Garnt and Connor chuckling)
It's like...
- You have ever like (indistinct)
(all laughing)
- I have seen a Japanese
YouTuber do that before.
- [Garnt] Oh God.
- Oh, well it go didn't
go out well though.
Oh yeah, I don't know, I
guess maybe it's because,
at least in Sydney bottled water is almost
non existent in Sydney.
Because legitimately the tap water is just
as good as the ball water.
- And also bottled water in
Australia is fucking expensive.
It's like, a bottle like
that big is like $4.
- I only buy bottled water because I'm out
and I can't just find a tap to drink.
(Connor chuckling)
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah no here,
because bottled water is cheap,
but t's like 100 yen,
so that it's a little bit more affordable.
But in Australia, if someone was like,
"Yeah, I'm just gonna go to the Woolies
- What about water fountains?
Do you drink from water fountains?
- I drink from water fountains
when I am desperate enough.
- It depends where.
- Yeah, it depends on where.
- And how clean or dirty
that water fountain is.
- I feel like a lot of this
has come up from my upbringing
cause in Thailand, you
can't drink tap water.
- [Joey] Right.
- So I've just gotten used to
like always buying bottled water.
- That makes sense.
- Okay, that makes sense.
- I do genuinely think
the taste of tap water
tastes like shit where I am.
- All right.
- I can taste the chalk where I...
- No in Brighton.
- All right.
- Yeah.
- It taste really metallic
I am not a fan of the metallic taste.
- I mean it was nice in Wales,
and here I felt it...
- But in London is fucking salty.
- Yeah, London I don't know,
but then in London you're
getting that like cholera shit.
(all laughing)
- I don't trust the water in London
I mean Wales is nice, the
quarry was right next to me.
- I feel like because,
I don't know how it is
but everywhere I've been to
where it's like a big city.
Normally I don't... tap
water tastes like shit.
- Countryside is.
- Like if okay,
- Like if you're in a hotel,
- And you're already thirsty,
do you go for the bathroom water?
Or do you go for the fridge minibar water?
- Yeah.
- Where you pay for it? No fucking way,
am I paying for that water.
- No, no I'm not paying that.
- 'Cause that's-
- He fucking did.
The hotel bathroom
water is like the worst.
- No dude,
- That's where I draw
- No dude, I'm never...
- I am never paying for water in a hotel,
- No.
(Garnt chuckling)
- That's ridiculous,
- That's ridiculous, it's like...
- I feel like a hotel is the one place
that should not be allowed
to charge for water.
(Joey chuckling)
Am literally paying.
- Like you're already,
- Like you're already
charging the (indistinct)
- I'm paying for a basic necessity,
which is just like being some where,
and you're gonna charge me for water?
Fuck off.
- Yeah.
- No way.
- I mean, for me, I genuinely can't taste
the fucking difference
anyway, so if I'm like...
- Shout out to hotels that give
out bottled water for free.
- Yeah, shout out that you are the G's.
(Joey chuckling)
- So I don't have to fucking
go through all the voss water.
- And not like just one
bottle they give you like four
and they're like go ham man.
We refill them all every day.
- Yeah.
And the best is when you
come back from a day out
and the bottles are like back, as well.
- Yeah.
- That's the good shit.
- On the topic of food,
so with it being Christmas right now,
and everyone just had
their Christmas meals
and everything like that.
- [Joey] Mm-hmm.
- What are your preferences,
in your Christmas meals?
Because, I'll be honest,
so last year, we all
celebrated Christmas together
and we had a hot pot.
- My mother traditionally left...
- It was it was a great
fucking hot pot but,
I aint gonna lie,
it just felt like something was missing.
- Yeah, it's not there's
not the fucking turkey
and whatever...
- Okay, I will say this,
I think turkeys overrated as fuck, man.
I don't understand the hype behind turkey.
- I think turkey is just
like an inferior chicken.
- It is, right?
Like imagine chicken but
just drier with less taste,
that's just turkey.
- Yeah.
- I don't understand,
why all the holidays...
- You know what it is?
It's someone who just got a turkey
and just went into Photoshop and did this.
(all laughing)
It's like everything is
thinner, it's just bigger.
- I think if you have
like a real nice turkey,
it's been like seasoned well you,
it's, I think it could
be better than chicken.
- No, because like, the
problem with turkey is that,
even if it's seasoned well, right?
You get the outer part,
that's nice and seasoned.
But then you get to the
inner fucking drier...
- That's why you gotta
cook it, you gotta cut it,
in a way you get the skin and
the bite in the same bite.
- But you can do that with chicken.
- Yeah, but...
- And with less price.
- Yeah, but I feel like
you can make a turkey
like skin taste better than chicken.
- I don't know, it depends.
- Meilyne agrees, and you know Meilyne.
- Yeah, but Meilyne's American.
do you like any other meats?
Cause sometimes my family
used to do like duck or ham.
- Yeah, like roast pork.
- I think all generally pork
is the best for Christmas.
- I think all generally, pork
and chickens like the
backup but I think...
- Really, I think a good
fucking ham is just like,
you can't beat that shit.
- Yeah.
- Define what you mean by ham,
do you mean like roast pork or like ham?
- You could do either, like...
- 'Cause I don't really like ham,
like roast ham.
- Does that guy like anything,
- I don't know like...
- What's wrong with you?
(Joey chuckling)
- You sounded like,
kind of like a gammon steak.
Kind of like,
- Yeah, it could be.
- Because I'm not a fan of gammon.
That's just like, the
inferior part of bacon.
- This man is not a fan of anything.
- It is literally the opposite.
It is literally the more expensive bacon.
(Joey chuckling)
That's literally what gammon is.
- I've never heard,
- I've never heard, what is a gammon?
like meatier cut of the pig.
- Oh, okay.
- And it's normally more
expensive than bacon,
'cause bacon is the
cheapest part of the pig.
- And it's shit and
gammon's like the actual...
I thank you very much.
- You been fucking brainwashed Garnt,
- How are you gonna argue with me,
that bacon is not the
best part of the pig?
- It's the most overrated part of the pig.
- Oh no, no.
- We never used to eat bacon.
Bacon used to be like the shitty part.
- I literally know vegetarians
who have been converted
to meat eaters because of bacon.
(Joey laughing)
- I think it's the meme, right.
Everyone says bacon is
like the best food, right?
- It's 'cause the smell of bacon,
- I just think bacon it's like,
it's not that great like,
it's just kind of tastes okay.
- Especially the American bacon.
- What the fuck are you talking about?
- American bacon is...
- American bacon is the best bacon.
- Oh, it's fucking awful.
- Oh, fuck off.
- It's the best bacon.
- Fuck off,
- Fuck off, stop clapping Meilyne.
- British back bacon,
is like the worst bacon.
- Its the best way to have bacon.
- No.
- I just don't love bacon period.
- Because right, normal
bacon is like 50 to 70%,
It's more fat than..
- Yeah,
and I'm not saying it's healthy,
but I'm saying it tastes
Like fat inherently just tastes like shit.
- No it, if it.
- The meat is the best part.
- No, no, no, no, no.
(Joey chuckling)
There's a reason why it's more expensive.
- The one thing I don't like about bacon,
is that it is way too overpowering.
Especially when you put
it with other things.
Like if you have like,
say like you put bacon
on a burger for instance,
a lot of people love that shit, right?
But for me, when bacon is on a burger,
all I taste is the fucking bacon.
Like I'd rather just have..
I'd rather just replace
everything with bacon
and will taste the same.
- It's like the nice
condiment that you need,
condiment that you need.
- I like bacon on my burger,
because I don't eat any ketchup or mayo
or fucking whatever on my burger,
I just...
- So you don't know sauce or
whatsoever on your burger?
- No.
- You're a fucking clown Garnt.
(Garnt chuckling)
I actually like,
- That's probably why he likes turkeys,
'cause it's like the driest fucking burger
- This man's like water this, water that.
- I want my bacon to be all fat,
just give me the fucking fat,
- Give me the driest fucking burger
and non-tap water please that's...
- Streaky bacon is like far
beyond the better bacon.
- What the fuck is streaky bacon?
- Streaky bacon is the American bacon.
- Okay.
- So I didn't know how like,
'cause whenever I...
- So to Americans, British
bacon is similar to Canadian,
- What's the difference?
- Yeah to America,
- To America, British
bacon is just like ham.
- So British is more like 80-90% bacon,
and it's like 10% fat on the edge.
- Yeah, it's like a thick (indistinct)
- [Both] Yeah.
- And like as a kid,
I would hate British bacon,
because I would just like
eat the bacon parts first
eat the bacon part first
cause that was the best tasty part,
'cause that was the best tasty part,
You're actually disgusting,
- No, no, no.
cause it wasn't..
- You would save fat and eat it.
- It wasn't he wasn't the fat part,
it was the fat with like the
little piece of meat in there.
And then I realized that,
American bacon is just all that.
So American bacon is just like
the best part of the bacon.
'Cause actually,
- We actually had a podcast for you
and then you sit here and tell
me you just wanna eat fat.
You just want fat.
And I'm supposed to give a
fuck about your food opinions?
- And this man doesn't eat
the crust on a pizza right?
(Garnt chuckling)
It's like the fatty part of a bacon,
is literary the equivalent of how you've
labeled crust on a pizza.
- No, it's the fucking opposite,
because the crust in the
pizza tastes like nothing
and the most tastiest part of
the bacon, is the fatty part.
That's why Americans have figured out,
the best tasting part of the bacon,
because they've just
taken the streaky bacon,
which is the most tastiest part
and put it all in one.
- You're beyond saving.
- We've lost this man,
- You're beyond saving,
- We've lost this man.
- You're beyond saving, unfortunately.
- If it's just the bacon
part, I've talked about this,
the bacon part, is just to me like pork,
is just vanilla beef.
We've talked about this,
(Joey chuckling)
unlike the only part that's better,
is the fatty part of the pork.
Like pork belly, pork
belly tastes fucking great
and that's mostly fat.
You gotta..
- Okay, I admit, pork
belly is fucking bomb,
- Yeah, that's 'cause..
- But that's because,
- Yeah, and it's also not
a very like cheap pork.
- Yeah.
- Bacon isn't anything cheap.
- Bacon is inherently cheap.
- That's an expensive part of the pork.
- The fat is good.
- It's because..
of the fatty content,
of the fatty content, that's
what gives it the flavor.
- 'Cause pork by itself,
- (indistinct) with more meat added.
- Yeah.
- So you get chunks where
you get a bit like half meat
But, that's like an actual
like richness to it,
'cause it's chunky.
- I just don't fuck
with the taste of bacon.
- And normally, pork belly
is not like on its own,
it's normally included with other things.
- It's like in a broth or something.
- Whereas like bacon,
it's like you can have
it with other things,
but again, it just overpowers everything.
- No one makes a fucking
broth out of bacon,
like that's just disgusting,
'cause it's shit.
excuse me.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Someone scrap that out please.
- When we spoke about the food episode,
we got really heated.
Like a day or two after Joey
was like, you know what Connor?
- Yeah, no, I thought about it,
- See.
- 'Cause in the food episode
as I agreed with Garnt
it's better than pork.
But then I thought I'm like no wait.
- Ton katsu, cuts it on,
- Tonkatsu, katsuzen that's all pork.
it's so shit.
- Maybe you can make a burger,
It's literally so limited,
that normally has meat,
is normally, pork block,
to the other side of the fence here
and say pork, yeah.
- Oh my God,
I can't believe.
- The fact that you...
- 'Cause pork.
that you like streaky bacon
over like actual meat,
just says the reason why you
can't appreciate good meat.
- For me pork just tastes...
- I rest my case your honor.
- Pork,
- Pork, just tastes like well done beef.
- Oh my God! Are you insane.
(shrieking)
- As we all know, nobody
fucking likes well done beef.
(crosstalk)
- No Garnt, I'm getting a call right now,
it's from the circus,
they want to they want to
know your address, bro.
Like what the fuck what?
you're the entire circus.
- It tastes nothing like beef.
- It tastes nothing like
beef. What are you on about?
- 'Cause the good, the
fucking best part of beef,
is like the moisture, and like, it's...
- Oh my God.
(chuckling)
oh duck is just a fatty chicken,
that's all it is, man.
(Connor chuckling)
It's like it's the same thing right?
It's the same thing right?
That's, they're not even
remotely similar in taste.
- Oh my God.
- I've never ever...
- Every chef who is watching this episode,
just had a stroke.
There's just like...
pretty realizes what a
fucking clown you are Garnt?
(Garnt chuckling)
- No, no.
(Joey chuckling)
I'm sticking my corner man,
beef is superior to pork.
- This man literally,
- Except for bacon,
- Garnt out here literally arguing,
his fucking like kiddie
meal preferences and food,
pretending is at the gourmet table,
like get out of here gourmet, come on.
- Oh my god.
- Yeah.
- Christmas.
- Anyway going back to Christmas meals.
- Going back to Christmas meals.
- I used to fucking hate Christmas meals,
'cause my parents used to make,
and they honestly they probably still do,
fucking awful gravy.
It's like jelly.
- Eewh!
- I feel like Christ
mas meals live and die
by the quality of gravy.
- It's true,
because I used to eat all of
the components on their own.
- Yeah,
- Because I refused,
to eat my parents' gravy.
And the whole family was
like, "What's wrong Connor?
Why are you doing it? It tastes good.
What do you mean?"
I'm like, "No, the KFC
gravy, although not great,
tastes better than this shit."
It's the consistency. Anything
that's jelly, I don't like.
- There's like a perfect middle, right?
'Cause if it's too jelly,
it's basically like a solid.
- It should be flake.
- But if it's like, I've had liquidity.
- It's the fucking...
- Gravy should...
- There's nothing
more depressing than watery gravy.
- You know right, when
you pour that shit in,
if it splashes, it's too...
It needs to like mold,
but not be like jelly.
- Like fucking, I'm calling you out mom.
do you guys like eggnog?
- I have, I...
- I've tried it once, I am not a fan.
- We don't have eggnog, Meilyne
just turned around and...
- [Meilyne] Japanese eggnog?
- [Garnt] Oh no.
- Meilyne just seems for eggs
- She said Japanese eggnogs.
- She said Japanese eggnog.
but then like two Christmases
ago when I went home,
my aunt, like handmade eggnog,
and you have that with like...
- It's like, do you like custard?
- It's okay.
- It's basically, think of
custard but it's a drink.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Yeah.
- And then my friend
introduced me to eggnog,
with a fireball and usually
I don't fuck with fireball,
i think fireball's overrated as fuck.
But that with eggnog
is like, It's so good.
Something like...
- You can have an apple
pie and drink eggnog.
I like it with the solid to like help.
- Well, that's why you have
it with the Christmas meal.
- Oh, Jesus Christ.
- I've been trying to
find eggnog in Japan,
cause I fucking love that shit.
'cause I fucking love that shit.
I just, it just doesn't sound good.
It just doesn't sound good.
Like it doesn't sound
like, I'll try though.
like the word 'eggnog',
like the word eggnog,
is the least appealing sounding word.
(both chuckling)
It sounds like eggnog.
- It's sounds like a dirty porno.
- I just think that,
- I just think that....
- Eggnog nine. My favorite porn.
(all laughing)
- I just, I feel like,
- I just, I feel like, 'cause
my family's like mega British.
So I don't have the Christmas meals to me,
It's probably this they
were 1000 years ago.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, right.
- Just people awkwardly sitting
around a table, being like,
"Yes, did you like your presents?"
I did like my presents mother.
"I did like my presents mother."
"Should we open a cracker?"
Do you have crackers in
Australia? Christmas crackers?
- Thought you mean like
white people? Like yes we do.
(all laughing)
Yes Connor...
- We have many crackers in Australia.
- [All] (laughing)
(all laughing)
- Basically.
You mean like on a cheese
platter and stuff like that or?
- Oh, those crackers?
- Yeah, Christmas crackers.
- No, what the fuck?
- Like Christmas crackers.
- Yeah with the ones with like little...
- With the ones with like little...
The Christmas crackers that you pull?
- Is that part of the American...
- You both pull an end of this cracker,
- Yeah and then whoever
gets the bigger half,
- And then whoever gets the bigger half,
gets the shit inside.
- Do you have this?
- It's like a kinderek.
It's like a kinderek but as a...
And then there's little things,
that like little plastic toys and stuff.
- [Garnt] And there's always
like one ready shit joke?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And you have like...
- And the paper crown.
- There's always a paper .
(Chuckling)
- Wow, America doesn't have this, huh.
- No America doesn't have that.
- Yeah, but we...
- Uncultured.
- You pull one of those,
they're overpriced,
they're like $10 for a pack of 10.
(Garnt chuckling)
And it's shit.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- When you're like five,
you're like this is fucking amazing.
- This is like death note
levels of like mind games,
but then you realize...
- I got six crowns (chuckling)
- I got six crowns.
(chuckling)
And then when you start
cheating you realize that,
because when you're,
because when you're the
one who's supposed to lose
(Joey chuckling)
And then they pull
And then they pull and you
realize it's not happening.
You're like fuck, I've been
called out, I've cheated.
- [Both] Yeah.
- Apparently in America,
- Apparently in America, it's not a thing.
- [Meilyne] It's a thing.
- No.
- Is it a thing?
- I heard, in some parts in
a lot of parts of America,
- I heard, in some parts, in
- I hated them.
- Yeah, I never got them.
- I never got them either.
- I don't like the idea of being teased,
for like 25 days on chocolate.
- It's like,
- It's not even a bar,
It's like a small amount.
- To me advent calendars,
to explain advent calendars
for anyone who doesn't know.
So you get a calendar at
the beginning of December,
and every day you can open
up like a day of the week,
and you get a different
piece of chocolate.
- God these white people.
- And..
- And unlike as as a kid,
(Connor chuckling)
it was just like the equivalent
of know not November,
but just for chocolate.
You know what I mean?
(Joey chuckling)
- It is the most blue balls of end,
(Garnt chuckling)
like Christmas right?
(chuckling)
Is it a morning thing? Or
is it an evening thing?
- I thought it was a morning thing.
- First thing in the morning,
you go you,
you go, it was like as a kid
it was it was the only time,
you could eat chocolate,
first thing in the morning.
- It was, but it was like
it threw off my vibe, right?
'Cause I was saying,
why am I fucking eating
Chocolate in the morning?
cause Christmas for us,
'cause Christmas for us,
is in like the middle of the summer.
(all laughing)
- You buy it and it's just like the...
you can see the chocolate kind of melting
from inside the thing,
you just open it is like
(Joey guffing)
(Joey chuckling)
are like the wooden ones?
- My parents would never fucking
buy me the expensive ones.
- Wooden advent calendars?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, the traditional...
- The traditional wooden,
like the traditional
advent calendars I've seen,
And then you open this like wooden door,
to open the chocolate.
(Garnt chuckling)
- My mom refused to pay
more than a $1 for mine.
- Yeah.
- So she would always,
wait until December 4th,
(Joey chuckling)
to get it.
And I remember being like,
And I remember being like, "Okay mom."
(chuckling)
- So three days of expired chocolate.
- Yeah, mom I see you,
I see what you're doing here.
(chuckling)
but for some reason to me,
advent calendar chocolate
just tasted better.
And I don't know why, like it's...
I have exactly the same opinions
I have no idea,
I have no idea, why?
'Cause it's the same Cadbury's chocolate,
it tastes 10 times better to me.
I don't know why.
I don't know why. I may the only one.
- I used to agree,
- I used to agree, because I
hadn't had an advent calendar,
- Yeah.
- And I was like, oh, fantastic.
I'm gonna be a kid again.
Cause I had one like three years.
'Cause I had one like three years.
And I ate it,
And I ate it, and I'm like,
wow, this is just shit.
(Joey chuckling)
This is shit.
I put them all out,
I put them all out, on like December 5th.
I grabbed them all up, put it in my hand.
- Did you guys, have the one where like...
- Squish them together.
- You're kind of like, it like
cracks out like a medicine?
- [Both] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I think it's cause you were a kid.
Because I,
Because, you know when
you're a kid, right?
Did they have these in
Australia, where they had?
So in the UK they have this
standard like $1, $2, eggs.
Which is just an egg,
maybe you get a chocolate bars as well.
- Yeah.
- But when you were a kid,
you'd always see the big egg.
- Yeah.
- I'm talking like $30, $40
egg, that was like giant.
(chuckling)
I feel like the magic is lost,
when you know you could buy it.
Because my parents were
never gonna buy me the $30.
They would never buy more than one egg.
So like, you don't need more than that.
And so when I was like, two years ago,
I bought the big egg.
- Right.
(chuckling)
- But it was reduced for like 10 bucks.
I had I thing it was gonna be fucking,
like God-tier experience,
came with its own shitty mug,
and two chocolate balls.
It was just fucking shitty chocolate.
(Joey chuckling)
It was just, it was awful.
I was like, wow!
- I'm the opposite.
- And then I realized, when I
put all this chocolate down,
it was like 300 grams of chocolate.
(Joey chuckling)
And I could have bought like...
- I think 'cause the inside's hollow.
- Because I could have bought
like five times the amount
of chocolate than when I paid.
We're fucking paying out the ass,
for them to put it in a fucking mold
and just fucking seal it together.
Are you kidding me?
- 'Cause the thing is-
- I'm a fucking clown.
- Logically my mind knows this.
But every time it's Easter,
like even as an adult,
like now that I am an
adult, I just buy one,
I eat it on the same day,
which is what something
I could never do before.
- Right.
And then the next day,
I'm in my local Tesco's or something.
I'm like, I'll go for another Easter egg.
(Joey chuckling)
I can do it.
And the thing is-
- Crack another one.
- And the thing is I always
buy the Cadbury's ones,
so that they always have
like the chocolates,
so it's always like Cadbury's
buttons or something.
And I know I can taste,
that it's exactly the same chocolate.
I don't know, it's
something about Easter eggs,
it's just like the right thickness,
t's just something about
eating an Easter egg,
that just makes you feel like a king.
- I actually prefer the ones,
that will like shaped out
like a rabbit.
- Yeah, those are pretty good.
- Yeah.
- Those are good.
- There's a good one lint one to Lenore,
those ones like thick as well.
- Yeah.
- So something, maybe
it's not just Easter eggs,
something about eating hollow chocolates,
that just hit different in my mind.
I don't know why.
- I don't know about that one too.
(Joey chuckling)
- I don't know what is
wrong in my psychology,
to be like chocolate
bar, get that shit away.
Hollow chocolate, okay,
let me nibble on this.
- I'm curious, is there...
Do you have a worst
or best Christmas present
you've ever received?
- Oh, God.
(sighing)
The best one I received,
I feel like the younger you were,
the better your Christmas present
at the time right?
- 100% dude, back when I could
just get a bunch of shitty toys
that lasted 10 minutes,
I was like, "What!"
- The probably best Christmas
gift I ever got was,
I got, Gameboy Advance.
- Oh shit.
- When I was like five,
and I played like the
shitty like Corby port.
That was like the SNES game,
which I found that ages
ago, was like $5 game.
(all laughing)
- I was just like, "This is
amazing father, thank you."
(Connor chuckling)
- Probably the best present
I've ever got was an N64.
And I think it was more
the experience around it,
because so I was at my
cousin's house and I opened it,
remember when game consoles,
were like the gods here,
of anything you could ever get?
- Oh yeah!
- Like no gift to compare.
- [Garnt And Joey] Yeah.
- You know your parents loved you,
when they got you a game console right?
(Garnt laughing)
It's like, "I feel truly loved,
thank you mother and father."
- Yeah, I remember my parents got me,
when I was I don't know
when that came out,
do you know when the Wii
was like impossible to get.
- Yeah, like 2005 or something.
- Yeah, and it was impossible to get.
Well they were like
all sold out in the UK,
when my dad worked in Germany
for like most of my life.
So when he came back for
Christmas, he brought me
and I was like, "Holy fuck,
how did you get a Wii?"
And then as we went to
plug it on Christmas day,
- Yeah.
- Couldn't fucking plug it in,
'cause he had the German plug.
(laughing)
And then 'cause my dad obviously
just forgot to buy one.
And I remember booting
it up and it being like,
(foreign language)
(laughing)
And then there were like the
thing, like control, warning.
(laughing)
I was like...
'Cause I think warning your attention.
- It was warning,
- It's like (foreign
language) or something.
I'm like, "What is this
dad? Dad, help me."
My dad couldn't fucking speak German,
so he was like, "I don't
know son, what are we doing?
I don't know."
I fucking had Wii sports but like,
and some other games..
- V sports.
(chuckling)
- I had some game and
the title was German.
I remember just I was like
so fucking confused as a kid.
I was like, "What the fuck is this?"
- I think I got the Wii for
Christmas as well actually,
now that I think about it.
- She was bald man. (crosstalk)
- But you know what ended up happening,
because it was when Wii
sports was like insane?
The day we got it working,
which is next day,
Wii sport, I couldn't fucking play,
'cause all my fucking older
relatives are playing,
Wii bowling drunk.
And I'm like, "When am I gonna
play Zelda? What the fuck?
This is my gift, what the fuck?"
(laughing)
Go on Garnt..
- 'Cause I just remember my ...
One of my best memories of the N64,
which is the first time
my boost up GoldenEye,
with my cousins.
I think that was my first proper like,
multiplayer experience,
'cause it was like "Whoa,
four people can play at the same time
and we can play together."
And at that time, that
was fucking mind blowing.
'Cause the best full play game back then,
was probably like fucking Bama man
or something like that.
- [Joey] Right.
- Mario Party maybe?
- No because Mario Party
wasn't out there yet.
- It wasn't out there.
- The first one was on N64.
(crosstalk)
- And I remember we
stayed up to like 4 a.m,
which back when I was a kid, was like...
- I might as well late,
not sleeping for two days.
(Joey chuckling)
- I might as well might
have been up for 40 hours.
- Whenever you get a brand
new game console man,
those endorphins are firing off.
- Oh yeah, of course.
- They're like, oh my God dude.
I don't really get that anymore.
- 'Cause you can afford everything now.
- Yeah, I guess so right?
- It's like doing a pine of cocaine.
- Like seeing the PS5 I'm
like, I know if I get it,
I'll play like Demon Souls and be like,
yeah, I'm sure like.
'Cause The Jumper is
not significant anymore,
- PS4 games can load 20% faster now.
- Yeah, cool, epic man,
oh, wow, really excited.
- Like going from SNES to
an N64 it's like, whoa!
- It's insane.
- 3D
You fucking kidding me, I
can walk in any direction?
What? Up is forward.
(laughing)
- What is this analog stick?
- Oh my God.
(laughing)
The cancer, that is the
fucking N64 control.
- Oh my God.
- I look at that thing
now, and I'm just like,
"How did anyone think
this was a good idea?"
- I love picking it up stone,
being like "God damn you
ugly son of a bitch."
(Joey chuckling)
I love you.
- I feel it again.
And I put my thumb on the
analog stick, and I'm just like,
"How is it this fucking hot?"
(Joey chuckling)
Like this is designed to give blisters,
how did this pass the ergonomics test?
- The moment I like put
my thumb on the joystick,
my palm just starts to hurt.
I'm just like the memories
of blistered palms doing
fucking this, my party too.
- You could get gloves from Nintendo
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they lost a lawsuit.
- Because of Mario Party won.
'Cause of the palm injuries.
- Oh yeah, my palm, I got destroyed...
- I couldn't believe that, it's insane.
- I just assumed the
design team at Nintendo,
the first day on the job,
they just took like an ergonomics book
and just set it on fire.
(Joey chuckling)
Its like, "Okay, we're designing
the N64 controller now guys."
- "Is it fun? Put it in?"
(Joey chuckling)
Man I remember as well that same Christmas
when we got the Wii.
My older brother got, not the Death Star,
what's the other big
battleship in Star Wars?
The one that's like a fucking like that.
- Oh the...
- Destroyer or something,
I don't fucking remember.
- Something like that.
- And then he built it all,
and for some reason had the amazing idea,
to put it near the TV,
in front of where we were with the Wii.
And I'm sure you can
imagine what happened.
- Oh yeah.
- It fucking hit the roof.
Someone did the bowling
through it, slammed the roof,
smashed down and destroyed this thing,
(Joey chuckling)
that he'd spent like eight
hours building, it was so funny.
I'll never forget that shit.
- Watching my dad playing Wii Sports,
is probably the funniest thing
I've ever seen in my life,
because I...
- Broomers get so into it.
(chuckling)
- Oh dude, he was so into
fucking Wii boxing as well.
It's like, of all the Wii sports ones,
(Garnt chuckling)
it was the fucking most intense one.
- I'm Mike Tyson, Joey watch.
- And oh my God just watching
my dad's fucking doing this
for like two hours, it's just so funny.
- I remember one Christmas,
I don't know how old I was.
So I was in Sunday school,
and I fucking hated Sunday school,
'cause why the fuck would
I wanna go, it was well,
when you are like eight,
I didn't understand why I cared about,
why I should care about Jesus and shit?
(Joey chuckling)
To me, I was like, "Who is
this guy? And why do I care?"
- Right.
- Who is this guy?
- Whose man's?
- Who's the big J man, that
everyone keeps talking about?
(laughing)
- And so, I remember this.
I fucking hated it.
My parents for some reason,
'cause my parents, right.
Not to out my parents here right?
(Joey chuckling)
But they said they were, religious.
My parents weren't fucking religious.
(Joey chuckling)
They just wanted to be...
It's literally like I feel
like the white suburban family.
It's like, wait, yeah,
we believe in Jesus.
- Yeah, we love J man.
- Yeah we love him, we're all...
You know, my, whatever.
And I'm like were not fucking religious.
I actually asked my mom and dad,
when was the last time
when they went to church.
And it's like, how many decades?
- 1972.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Right, so they put me...
they had the genius idea
to put all of me and my
brothers, in Sunday school.
And my older brother, he
never complains about stuff.
He just gets on with it.
- Right.
- And me, you know me, I like to complain.
Okay, before we get into your story.
- [Connor] Okay.
- What is Sunday school?
- Oh, you don't know, okay true.
- It's like a church school, right?
- So yeah, I mean, it's
in America as well.
I think it's more popular in
America, but in the UK as well,
it's normally for like Christian stuff
or Catholic or whatever.
- What do you learn in Sunday school?
Because I've never been to Sunday school.
- Jesus.
(chuckling)
- I just know about Sunday school.
- So I think I was too young,
to do the super religious stuff.
So 90% of the time, they
just spoke about religious,
they would tell stories.
And I remember being like,
"Who the fuck cares."
And also, I remember
coloring in so many pictures,
so many fucking pictures.
(Joey chuckling)
And I remember...
- Did you have a Jesus coloring book?
- Yeah, we had like a Jesus coloring page.
- Oh my God.
- And I fucking hated it.
'Cause I was like, "Who is
this guy? Why do I care?"
(Joey chuckling)
- Why am I coloring this guy?
- This is the fifth time
we've colored in his birth.
Do we really need to
keep coloring this man?
I do remember being like,
and also one time, and it was, you know,
I'd watch TV shows in American cartoons.
And they have like the paddling bowls.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I have this very very vivid memory.
- Yeah.
- Of one time one of the kids bringing
in the paddling balls, and it was like
the coolest fucking thing.
- Yeah.
- And they immediately
took it away from him.
And I was like, "No I wanna
play with the paddling ball."
- Why did they take away from him?
- I don't know, 'cause it's Jesus time.
(laughing)
- No one interrupts Jesus.
- And they made us do
like a play at Christmas,
when I was like eight or nine.
- Oh well like the birth
of Jesus and stuff.
- Yeah.
- I think that my school did that as well.
- But it wasn't in school though,
we had to do it in fucking Sunday school.
- What role did you get?
- I had to give meh.
And I remember being
like, "Mom, I don't..."
- You were one of the wise men?
- Yeah, I was one of the wise men.
- Oh, man you got a big role.
- I was the snowman.
(laughing)
- But I think this 'cause, I think.
(Joey chuckling)
- That was literally what I did.
I literally just did this on stage.
- Thank you Jesus.
- And then my mum still
has pictures being like,
(Garnt applauding)
"Great performance, great performance."
(hands clapping)
(Joey laughing)
- I think I was one of the wise men,
only because I, there wasn't enough kids,
to fill the other roles.
(laughing)
- Because there wasn't
enough kids in the school.
I hated it. I remember.
And then also, I was like," Why
do I have to have meh, mom?"
He's got gold. I want gold.
That's bullshit.
And I didn't know how
to say meh at the time,
when I was a kid.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Why, it's just...
(both bleating)
- Gold, I know gold mother.
Come on, give me ...
(Connor chuckling)
And I remember we had
to do this shitty play.
And I was like, I hate
this so much. I hate it.
And so for one Christmas,
I asked my mom I was like,
she was like, "What do
you want for Christmas?"
- Meh.
(chuckling)
- I dead ass looked her in
the eyes, and I was like,
"I don't care about gifts.
Just please don't make
me go to Sunday school."
(Joey chuckling)
I want my Sundays back mom.
"I'm going to school five days a week
and then another day I have to turn up
and fucking color pics of Jesus,
are you kidding me?
I hate this shit."
And I think honestly, that's
the reason why I just care
for like zero religion now.
Because they pushed it so heavily on me
and I'm like, this is shit.
It's all a bunch of nonsense.
- Yeah.
- We're reading books,
stories about this dude,
who I don't give a fuck about,
like there's no college.
- So you went to you went to
a Catholic school as well?
- No, it wasn't a Catholic school
but they did make us
pray, three times a day.
- Wait so, what?
- So in Wales, a lot of
schools should make you pray.
- Oh.
- 'Cause it's just like a
religious country in general.
- Even if it's an atheist school.
- There's no atheist school.
It's just, it's a school and
then a lot of them have like...
- It's just a school.
- Yeah.
(both chuckling)
- In my secondary school
and my primary school,
I think you pray three times a day.
- Oh, really?
- But the thing is
right, that you realize,
maybe like in high
school, you're like, oh,
they won't tell you
off, if you don't pray,
'cause they can't.
'Cause it's a religious thing.
- But it's still a school rule?
- Well, no, it's...
- Like a school suggestion?
- it's like a cult right?
Because when you get in this thing, right?
You go to school and then
everyone suddenly bows their head
and starts fucking speaking in tongues.
- Right.
- You're like, "Oh, shit, I
should probably join in on this,
I don't wanna be the only one left out.
But then you realize after on,
they're not gonna do
anything if I don't pray
and just stand there and
look around and be like,
"What's going on?"
You see all the other kids.
And so I would just refuse
to do it eventually.
'Cause I'm like, I'm not praying.
I don't believe in this nonsense.
I don't understand why they made us do it.
Because we weren't a religious school.
- That's the thing, it's
like I find that a bit weird,
'cause it would make sense if
you went to a Christian school
or a Catholic school.
- It might have been like,
it wasn't officially a Christian school,
but like a lot of the
schools in Wales were like,
Christian and school, something.
- I think just a lot of schools
in England are like that,
anyway, because, I don't
think I went to a Catholic
or religious school.
- No I do.
- We still did religious
things around Christmas time.
And I had no idea what
the fuck was going on.
- Yeah fuck.
- 'Cause I come from a Buddhist family.
So we'd have events in the
church and stuff like this.
I'm like, "This isn't a temple."
(Joey chuckling)
"What is this?"
- God, it's just like singing Welsh hymns,
I know that the fucking
voice didn't get to me.
- I had to sing hymns as well.
I had no idea what they..
- Me neither there was one, It was called
(speaking foreign language)
and it means cum on my head.
(both chuckling)
- And so...
- J man please.
(laughing)
Behave yourself,
I know it's your birthday
and all but fucking hell.
- It's literally called like
(speaking foreign language)
It literally translates to cum my head.
Every time they would like...
'cause there was a sheet of 12 hymns
and they would never do
(speaking foreign language)
because everyone would always like,
look at each other and giggle
and because the chorus was
just shouting, like loudly,
♪ Dod ar fy mhen ♪
(both chuckling)
- They would never pick it,
'cause everyone would just
start screaming, cum on my head.
(all laughing)
In Welsh.
'Cause we're all fucking kids.
- Right, right.
- And we found it funny.
And every time they'd pick it,
it was like a fucking event,
because every old...
It was the one time where,
all the kids who didn't really sing
and go
(mumbling)
and would start, would proudly sing like..
- They'd be like-
- All right boys in queue right?
(Connor chuckling)
(Joey clearing voice)
- That's weird because I went to...
my high school was a Catholic school.
- Yeah.
- Even though I'm not Catholic personally,
but we didn't even have to
do the whole praying thing.
We would have to do, maybe
like an end of term mass,
or like a beginning of term
mass and stuff like that.
- [Both] Yeah.
- That's like bring on the new year
but yeah, we never had to do any...
- I did, it was one of those
things that when you left,
you're like, "That was weird, wasn't it?"
(Joey chuckling)
"That was weird that they made us pray."
We were like pray before every
meal and stuff, and like..
- That's a bit weird.
- Yeah, it is weird. What's
up with that Wales, man?
And eventually my parents did grant
my Christmas wish and start...
- Oh really?
- [Garnt] Oh really.
- Got you out of it?
- 'Cause I...
- At what age?
- Fuck, it was before I
started secondary school,
so it must have been..
- How long were you in there for?
- I think like two or three
years. Fucking hated it.
- You make it sound like a prison.
How long were you in there for?
- How long were you in?
(Garnt exclaiming)
- I literally...
- Have you readjusted to society now?
- The amount of times I
was like, "Mom, I cannot.
I know you think this is
just me being a fucking kid,
but I fucking hate this."
(Joey chuckling)
Please, take me out of this."
- Honestly, as a kid,
like anything religious,
was just the most boring thing for me.
Like I remember whenever
my mom would take me
to temples and everything to go pray
and talk to the monk and everything.
I just wanted to go home
and play N64 honestly.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- I'm just like this,
what's fun to do here?
There is literally nothing fun to do here,
in this religious place.
- This is why like when you
see like those families,
who like their kids,
just get like indoctrinated
into the (mumbling)
Raised into the... I
think it's indoctrinated.
- Indoctrinated.
- I think so,
(Joey chuckling)
they got...
- Call out to anyone who's religious.
(both chuckling)
- They're like the super
religious people, right?
'Cause I remember even was like eight,
and I would hear these things like,
"He turned wine into water."
And I remember being like eight years old,
like did he though?
Did he? I've never seen anyone do that?
Pretty...
- I'm actually...
- But I'm gonna be like, that
sounds a bit bull shit to me.
- Just press X to tell.
(chuckling)
- I do remember vividly being
like, I don't know about that.
- Think so it didn't happen.
(chuckling)
- Yeah.
It's the same thing with Santa Claus,
like my parents would try
and tell me at like age 10
that Santa was real.
I'm like, "I'm not having any of that."
Come on.
(Joey chuckling)
Reindeer's that can fly?
Come on mom.
- That's a question.
At what age did you figure
out, that spoilers alert,
Santa isn't real.
- Oh, dude, I've like
went on an operation,
at midnight to like find out.
(Joey chuckling)
To prove...
- You did like the stealth mission?
- To prove to them, that I
knew what they were doing.
And I found out.
- I found out accidentally,
because I think it was
maybe like 10 or 11.
And it was Christmas night
and I was like, fuck,
I really need to pee.
I drank too much, whatever it was.
(Connor chuckling)
And I got up in the middle of the night.
My dad was like this, next to the tree.
(Garnt laughing)
And he just caught me red handed
and he's like,
all right son it's time you found out.
- [Both] (chuckling)
- It's time you knew the truth.
- You got me kid.
- [Both] (chuckling)
- I think I know where,
because, you know,
I did like a thorough sweep of the house.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
- But you know, a few days before,
I'm like,
they'll be presents here.
My theory is correct.
My hypothesis.
Couldn't find any presents in the house,
and I was like,
they must be hidden in the garage.
So I was like, great,
I'll wait till midnight,
on Christmas until they bring them in.
And as I slept, right,
it was like covert ops.
Just pretending to sleep.
My parents came in to
check if I was sleeping.
- Yeah.
- And I wasn't.
- So I don't remember the
exact age I found out,
like Santa wasn't real.
But I remember as a kid,
I was like, the smartest
dumb kids in existence,
because I would like be figuring out,
all these like logistics of how Santa,
could be able to send
these presents rounds.
'Cause there would be
years, where you know,
I wouldn't be at home.
So I'd be like,
"How's Santa gonna figure
out I a aint home?"
(Joey laughing)
- You'd be that sober?
- Yeah.
So, we'd be sitting at
my cousin's house, right?
And the presents would still be there,
even though we were staying
at my cousin's house,
no matter where we were every year.
And for some reason, it just
didn't click to me as a kid,
that Santa wasn't real.
But, instead of just realizing
that Santa wasn't real,
I was in my head.
I was like, "So this is how
Santa knew I was staying here."
So we went to our house,
didn't see I was there.
Saw like, the notes that I left somewhere,
or saw, like the phone call,
that I had with my cousin,
that will come around to his house.
So that's how Santa knew,
that I was staying
around my cousin's house.
And I explained this to
my parents at the time,
and my parents just like,
"Yeah, you've figured it out."
- You got them
- "You've figured it out."
You've out-smarted Santa.
- God damn it, he's smart.
- You're like the whiteboard
with like the pins on it,
'cause like does he
operate like time zones?
Like how does it look? Yeah fucking help.
- I think I just remember being like,
"Damn, none of this Jesus
stuff seemed to have happened."
(Joey chuckling)
When I was like 10, I don't
know if this Santa stuff's real.
'Cause none of this shit's happening,
I'm trying wine.
- Did you ever do like...
I think it's just like an American thing,
but did you ever do leave
like the the cookies
and the milk?
- Yeah, we did that.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- We didn't do that.
- I didn't do that.
- Yeah.
- I think that my dad just wanted food.
- I saw this brilliant,
Reddit post of like a dad, being like,
"So my son's left cookies and
milk on his bedside table.
But how do I tell him that
Santa is lactose intolerant?"
(laughing)
"Do I just drink the milk and
take the shits for my son?"
- Well...
- "Do I leave it there
and break his heart?"
(chuckling)
- I remember one time my dad was like,
"No, no, no Connor, Santa likes beer."
(laughing)
- I'm definitely doing that to my child.
- [Garnt] Oh my God.
- And so he legit poured beer for himself
And then just drank it obviously.
(both chuckling)
'Cause he poured cold water for himself.
(all laughing)
- I was gonna be to my son, I'm like,
"Did you know that Santa
loves gin and tonic?"
- Yeah Santa likes, an espresso Martini.
- Leave the gin and tonic,
it maybe be as cheese platter on there.
That will do, I mean Santa
will definitely eat that.
- The double of course.
(both laughing)
- Double shot.
- Santa, doesn't like
cookies, he like brownies,
but like the special brownies.
- Yeah, the special brownies.
- Give Santa the special brownies.
- Yeah, Santa loves G Fuel.
(Garnt chuckling)
Just put a cup of G Fuel
next to the brownie.
- I can't believe that your
dad did not say that to you.
- That is so big brain.
- 'Cause he just wanted a beer.
- That is being brain as fuck.
- 'Cause he knows that we believe it.
Like I believed that it wasn't real,
but I also was like, maybe, a little bit,
there's a chance that someone's
drinking this, and yeah...
- I mean Santa is a grown
adult, you know he might...
He's working hard.
- Possibly driving and drinking,
(Joey chuckling)
but I mean, that's okay.
- Like, question to you guys.
Do you normally have like a normal...
What's your Christmas Day like?
What's your typical Christmas Day like?
Do you have any schedules?
Do you have any like...
- Used to have, you'd
open presents first thing.
Which is always the best part,
but it always goes downhill from there.
(both chuckling)
- Do you remember the age where,
you just couldn't sleep before
Christmas, as a teenager,
you're just like, "Dude, I
don't care about this any more."
- Well, because you
realize, when you were like,
I don't know, did you always
use to pick a lot of things
and you would get some of them,
or did you get everything that you picked?
- I would get some of them.
- No,
- Because my parents would also be like,
"Listen, Connor, Santa's got a budget."
(both chuckling)
And I was like, "Really?"
So then I had to look for the
products within the budget.
- Right.
- And then I never connected the dots,
(Joey and Garnt chuckling)
you know, from age eight or whatever.
But I would go through like,
we had to think of like Argos.
- Oh, Argos.
- What's that?
- It's like a...
they had like a giant,
fucking gigantic booklet.
- Imagine the most depressing
store you can think of,
you go into the store, right?
And it's not a store, It's
just a store of catalogs.
So imagine like Amazon warehouse,
but it will have a slight...
- Like an Amazon IRL.
- Yeah.
- So you'd go in, you could book it online
or back then you had to go to the store
and take off the boxes you wanted.
According to the catalog.
- Seems depressing is fun.
- Yeah it was.
- 'Cause the cats...
(Garnt chuckling)
- As a kid though, this shit was magical,
'cause it had like everything in it.
- Right.
- So you would go through
and now you realize
this was just fucking overpriced.
- Yeah.
- With all the shit lost, but
back then there was no Amazon,
so you're fitting it in the budget.
- Yeah, because how are
you going through it,
'cause back back in the day,
you didn't really have the internet.
So you'd have to hold off this catalog.
So you go into this at Argos store.
And there was this catalog,
that was like as thick as a brick.
You could fucking murder someone
with this catalog, right?
- Your phone book?
- You'd go in and you
flip to like the index.
You'd go in and usually like (indistinct)
- Case closed.
- It's right under act as well.
- And so you flip through the index
and go through like the game
sections and the toy sections,
which was the only sections
you really looked at.
- [Joey] All right.
- And then it was just
like free picking space,
- I never had anything...
- And then basically, when I
turned off Christmas morning,
there'll probably be a few surprises,
but most of the stuff that
I wanted would be there.
Except that one time like I said,
that kind of upset, fucking
dad bought me cricket tickets.
(Joey chuckling)
- Which he did a lot.
- I clearly expressed
my disdain for cricket
but I thought this is
gonna change his life.
- I genuinely like other
than the Gameboy Advance,
I genuinely don't remember
what else I got, from Santa.
- One Christmas I just got like all Yukio,
like I got the fucking jewel
arm thing and I got like...
- Oh, you got one of those?
- Yeah, I got...
- Aargh, jealous.
- All my friends have got one as well.
- Jealous.
- We would turn up to
school and we play Yukio,
but then they just stopped
playing after they realized,
my dad is spooky.
- I guess Santa didn't have
the budget for that for me.
- Yeah.
(chuckling)
- I feel like I asked for one year,
but I just didn't get it.
- [Garnt] I mean...
- Dad was like, "Fuck this
little shit, doesn't need that."
- I think he just got me like
a bunch of booster packs.
- He has the graveyard
and the fold out thing,
with the back of the
booster pack, he'll be fine.
- Yeah, he'll be all right.
- I remember for me, it
was always video games.
I never asked for
anything but video games.
And that was because as a kid,
there were only two times in the year,
when I could get new video games.
- Right.
- And one of them was my birthday,
and the other one was Christmas.
- Which is a fucking rare occasion,
if I managed to get a game
outside my birthday or Christmas.
- Yeah exactly.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, so I remember, it was
the highlights of my year,
because I'll be like,
"Finally I can play something
other than Super Mario 64
for like this like millionth time."
(Joey chuckling)
And so, I couldn't get every game,
so I normally get like two,
if it was like a fucking special year.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- It was like, I knew my parents loved me,
when I got three video games man.
- Yeah, three games, is like
the limit for me as well.
- Yeah.
- It's like 100 quid, 120 pounds.
- We're pushing it.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Yeah, so I mean, that's probably why,
I always remember the N64.
'Cause the N64 was just like God modes.
- [Joey] Yeah.
- Like I had never gotten a
bigger present in my life,
at that moment.
- Now that you say that,
I think I remember why I wanted to...
Why I kept doing like chess
stuff and being good at things,
because my parents buy me shit.
(Joey chuckling)
If I wanted things,
they would buy me stuff.
So I said I should just win
the stuff that I'm good at
and they'll keep buying me things.
(Joey chuckling)
'Cause whenever I like win
a tournament or whatever,
they'll go and buy me a game.
I'm like, stonks.
(Joey chuckling)
Let's just get good at something.
- I think that was me,
but just with school
and especially Japanese for me.
Like if I did well in like my
Japanese tests and whatnot.
My mom would be like,
"Yes, that is my son."
- My brother was always
better. So it didn't matter.
I was like, "I gotta find another niche."
- Oh, fair enough.
- Do you have any family
traditions at Christmas?
- We just have like family come over...
- We have two parties, we have,
one Christmas Eve so like 24th,
the night we would have kind of bring,
all that family friends over.
- Yeah.
- So all my childhood friends and whatnot,
and friends from school
and whatnot, come to ours
and then Christmas Day,
the next day is when it's like family.
Like during the day.
- For me it's the other way round.
Family day it's like completely sober,
it's like Christmas Day.
Boxing day is when the
fucking party is at.
Where we get drunk with the family.
- Now Boxing days is recovery day for us.
(both chuckling)
- Boxing days is like, "We've
had two parties back to back,
we've gotta recover."
(Joey chuckling)
- Stuff like family come over I think,
and have a nice little get together.
- It's nice for us as well,
because at my parents place,
we have this...
because it's during the
summer in Australia.
We have this big...
We have like an out place,
with this like big backyard like deck,
that looks over everything
and so just crack open a cold beer,
in like the fucking 30 degree summer,
on a Christmas is fucking awful,
- I keep forgetting that.
- That's weird to me.
- Or we go to my uncle's
place and we jump in his pool,
and we just do the pool
all day on a Christmas Day.
- It was it was super weird for me,
like two three years ago,
when I was living in Thailand.
And we were celebrating
Christmas in Thailand.
And it was just like, 30 degree heat
and us opening Christmas
presents under a Christmas tree.
And I'm like, "This
isn't very Christmassy."
(Garnt chuckling)
- I'm sweating man.
- This doesn't feel very Christmassy.
I have to put the AC on.
- Yeah.
- I mean, okay. Have you
ever had a white Christmas?
- Yeah.
- I've had it once.
- Once.
- So my family most of the time,
preferred like go on like
vacation for Christmas.
I think that just they
love going on vacation.
And the stuff they always
used to do is like,
"We're not gonna buy you stuff Connor,
we're gonna take you places."
Which I appreciate now.
But as a kid I fucking hated it.
- Right?
- I'm like, "I don't wanna
go to fucking France, mom.
I fucking hate France. Everyone
in France is a dick head.
can't you just get me the new Game board."
- You don't see family on Christmas.
- So it depends on, I
think every other year,
So so we would sometimes
go skiing or snowboarding.
Which sounds fucking epic now.
(crosstalk)
- Your family have the right idea man.
They are big brain.
- But you know, when I was a kid,
I'm like, 'I don't want
to fucking be away,
this is my time off,
you're making me do work."
'Cause to me right,
skiing and snowboarding with
my family was like a chore,
when I was a kid.
- Right.
- Because they're so fucking slow.
I would have to like go on a ski thing,
and I would just be like,
I would wait at the top.
- Come on peasants.
- I would wait at the top
and I'm like, just go ahead.
I'll be down. I'll follow you
and I would wait for
five minutes on my phone.
And then when I was like,
it's been five minutes time
to go like full speed down
and catch up and like overtake them.
- Yeah.
- And I used to wait,
and then you know also when you're a kid,
and you don't have money,
I'm fucking hungry as shit
and these results, 'cause like,
we would go on like packages.
So they were pretty cheap.
Not that am trying to bash my parents,
(Joey chuckling)
I'm very grateful,
but they were like the
cheapest possible way,
that you could go to like Italy and ski.
- Right.
- Which is fair enough.
I mean I applaud the effort,
but when you had to eat
out at these places,
they like charge a lot
for like food and drinks.
- Oh yeah!
- She was like,
"We're getting one meal between us all.
We're all gonna split it."
and I'm like, "Fuck mom I'm starving."
(Joey chuckling)
"I would not,
for more than one sixth
of the pizza right now."
- Right.
(both chuckling)
- Please, but going now as an adult,
I have my own money.
I'm like, I'll waste all
my money on the food there,
I don't give a fuck, I wanna be full.
- Because like these activities,
I've realized the reason we
enjoy them so much as an adult.
- Do you do with friends?
- Yeah, not just that.
But because we can get alcohol involved.
(both chuckling)
- Like you know what I mean?
It's just like going on
trips and everything,
it just fun out with a pine and...
- Oh it's 9 a.m it's time for flying.
- Yeah, 'cause what you do after
you have your fun activity,
and you just want to wind down?
As a kid you have fucking nothing to do.
But as an adult, you can just,
get drunk with the boys and us.
- Yeah, I enjoy spending
more time with my family
now that I'm an adult, than
I did when I was a kid.
- Yeah, exactly.
- 'Cause I've worked, I've
had three white Christmases
and all three of them have been
because I was working at
a ski resort in Japan.
- Let's say having a white
Christmas in Australia.
- Oh, no. That's a different
type of white Christmas.
(Garnt chuckling)
But yeah, like I had
the whitest Christmases
in like ski resorts
because it's just
fucking white everywhere.
But like, the only difference
between the Christmas night,
at a ski resort and every other night,
is that there's just more
white people outside really?
(Joey chuckling)
That's the only difference,
because what do you do at a ski resort?
Other than skiing and snowboarding?
You get shit faced?
Yeah, that's the only...
- Sauna, is normally a good chance.
- Yeah. Oh, like on sauna, right?
Like, other than that,
It's like the only other thing,
if you if you wake up in the morning,
you're like, "Oh, man, my
body's feeling a bit sore,
I don't wanna go skiing or snowboarding."
There's nothing to do during the day,
other than to go to the
one bar that's open 24/7
and just gets shit faced.
- And also because like,
fucking skiing and snowboarding,
is so fucking exhausting.
- Oh yeah.
- You're like,
"Alright, that fucking
pine is like amazing."
You've ever been skiing or snowboarding.
- I've never been skiing or snow boarding.
- It's always been...
- I mean, like, the reason
I've never been is just 'cause,
every holiday we went to Thailand,
- Yeah, it's also one of those
things where I feel like,
I don't know why my family just were like,
let's just go skiing for the first time.
I feel like normally you go
with someone, who's been.
- Yeah.
- So they can be like,"
I'll help you out."
- Yeah. Also like skiing lessons.
- Skiing lessons yeah.
- [Connor And Joey] Yeah.
- Also, you know, when I was growing up,
I wasn't in the most privileged position,
where my family could kind of afford that,
because I feel like going skiing
is like an expensive holiday.
Or can be, expensive.
- Yeah, it is. I mean...
- 'Cause,
- Especially if you're in
a country that doesn't have
like resorts nearby.
- Exactly.
- Exactly right.
- You know what I realized this,
when I started flying for like
conventions and stuff, right?
I was I always thought,
the airports were even worse
than they actually are.
Because right, if you get
one of those package deals,
the company that does the
package deal, charters the plane.
- Right.
- So you all have to like wait
in this fucking horrible line
these planes are like the fucking worst.
And the people are the worst as well.
- Yeah.
- It's like the worst
kind of British tourists.
- Yeah, which I'm sure
you've all seen videos
of you watch like Apple meltdowns.
It's always British people, always.
- Right.
- Dude these these fucking
flights are awful, it's the most,
oh, God.
(Joey chuckling)
You've been on them?
- I've been on okay, so
the most depressing place
I've been to on earth I
think, is Luton Airport.
- Oh, it's awful.
(Connor clearing voice)
- Or in UK?
- In the UK?
- Yeah.
- Okay, so we stayed, so
you know, back before...
back when I was just like
fucking poor and all that stuff.
We booked this holiday.
It was me and Sydney at the time.
So we booked this holiday
on this like budget airline,
that flew out of Luton,
and I remember to save costs,
when needed to stay near Luton,
'cause it was actually
cheaper to stay near Luton,
than to like get there in the morning,
in the like rush hour.
- Right.
- And so we picked the cheapest hotel,
which happened to be Easy hotel,
- [Connor] Oh, no!
- Which I didn't know,
- That already sounds (indistinct)
- Okay, so in Europe,
there's this there's this
budget airline called EasyJet.
- It's the worst.
- And it's the worst, one
of the worst airlines.
I wouldn't say it's the worst,
- What's worse Ryanair?
- I'd say Ryanair.
Ryanair is fucking (indistinct)
- There just both two
sides of the same coin.
- Anything that flies out Luton,
is automatically like horrible for me.
But like, so we stay in Easy hotel,
and I've never felt like I've paid
to stay in a prison cell before,
(Joey and Connor chuckling)
- Until I stayed there.
So it was like we go in
and there's literally like no windows.
- It's just a white
room right, with a bed.
- Yeah, it's just a black room.
And like the walls are paper
thin and they were like,
I could hear at least like
three different people,
fucking in different rooms.
(Joey and Connor chuckling)
- You know what I mean?
And I go into the shower, right?
- It's a shared shower right or is it?
- No, no, you had your own private shower,
but it was...
(Connor exclaiming)
- That's one step up isn't it?
- But like there wasn't even like a door
to like separate the
shower from the bed, okay?
So so it was just like curtains,
so you open up these curtains
and then there is like a toilet seat
and then there is a
shower right next to it
and it just it was the like definition
of how I imagined a
prison shower to be right?
(Joey chuckling)
'Cause the only thing said that...
'cause there's nothing
separating the toilet
from the shower.
- [Joey] Right.
- So you just showering and so
what while you're showering,
the toilets just like
getting fucking soaked,
and everything like that.
And it's got like the gray
kind of like floor as well.
So if you felt like I
was in a prison cell,
and I had to pay good money.
- How much was it for like, a night?
I can't remember, like 20 quid a night.
- Oh, fuck hell.
- Yeah.
- I would have rather
stayed in prison cell.
(crosstalk)
- It just like me and Sydney there,
but I was like, I better
not drop the soap man.
(both chuckling)
- I better not drop
the soap while am here.
- Something will just burst
through the fucking walls like,
(growling)
- Its just like Ryanair and EasyJet,
if you forget your ticket,
they charge you like 50 euros or...
- I got charged that when we flew from
fucking Amsterdam to Ireland.
- I got charged that as well.
- Did you?
- Yeah I did.
- I've never wanted to smack
an attendant in my life right,
but when she said that,
I was like my hand is
my backhand is ready.
- Yeah and like if you have
over like five kilograms
or something, which is like,
what you're obviously going to have over.
- Yeah.
- They charge you like 50
pounds to bring a carry on.
It's ridiculous.
- So dumb.
- It's awful (indistinct)
- Because it's right in this fine print,
where they tell you you
can't check in, right?
- [Joey] Yeah.
- And I think that's the big one,
I understand, not having,
not be able to check in or everything,
but like putting it in
like the fine print.
- Yeah.
- That's just a dick move.
- Yeah, it is like, what is it like?
Like Argso designs.
- Yeah.
(Joey chuckling)
That is it.
- And they have like a million
ads, before you even get to,
you wanna like get to,
like the amount of fucking rental cars,
they fucking try and show you,
is up the ass online.
(Joey chuckling)
- It's like no, no.
- And also even if the
plane is completely empty,
they won't let you choose seats
and they on purpose scatter you,
so that they force you to pay
to sit next to each other.
- Right.
- But I'm like fuck that.
- Yeah, we're not doing
that, I don't give a fuck.
(Joey chuckling)
I'll see him when I land. Who fuck cares.
- Yeah it's like that.
- I'm not that desperate,
that I need to be within a
two meter radius of my friends
all the time, Jesus Christ.
- We have something similar in Australia,
It's called Jetstar.
- Every every fucking
like continent has that.
(Joey exclaiming)
- That's so bad.
I fucking flew Jetstar once
from Sydney to Brisbane.
And it was like an hour and a half flight,
but it's the worst fucking
flight I've ever been on.
- God.
- Like delayed three hours for no reason.
And then you get there
and then it's like 60 million years
for the luggage to come
out on the other side.
I'm just like, where's is this luggage?
- God it's like, you've been on Norwegian?
You've been on Norwegian right.
- I've been on them.
- You'll fucking hate Norwegian airlines.
- It's all right.
- Norwegian's okay.
- It's not, oh my God.
- Like compared to other budget airlines,
Norwegian is like the Rolls
Royce of budget airlines man.
(Joey chuckling)
- Like.
- No, it's 'cause it's
the only budget airline,
that's like long haul I swear,
and you can do you can
have a 12 hour flight
and they will give you no food.
- Really?
- Yeah.
- On Norwegian?
- You have to pay.
- Oh, yeah.
- Yeah but like any any budget
airline that has movies,
- I think...
- That has a movie choice is already,
like better than 90% of...
- I think it only has movies,
because they don't make those planes,
the ones that do long haul,
without them built in.
- Yeah, right.
- I don't think they do that anymore.
I don't think it's possible,
I'm sure if they could
have removed the TVs
and made you pay for them,
I'm sure they would have.
(Joey chuckling)
But like the fact that
they can go 12 hours
and not give you food, like blows my mind.
- I've never been on
Norwegian airline that long.
- Don't.
- Yeah.
- I'd say I've been on worse,
- And and also it's a 12 hour flight right
and they try and they charge
you for like a carry on.
- Where the fuck were you flying to?
- LA to UK.
- UK to LA,
- And always Norwegian.
- Really?
- Because they were by far the cheapest.
- You guys didn't have
like American or United
or anything?
- There's America.
- But then-
- So-
- But they were more
like double the price.
- All right.
- Broke as fuck, so it
was like either Norwegian,
which was pretty consistently
always like 400 bucks.
Return.
- Jesus.
- From London to LA
and then the next stop,
was like United which was like 500
but back then is like 100 bucks.
I was like, that's a big deal.
Like that's a slightly better hotel.
- Oh, it wasn't 400 to 500,
it was like 400 to 600.
- 600 to 700.
- Yeah, true.
- I think you got what you paid for.
I think that Norwegian
is good for the price.
And if you're like someone broke,
who's trying to go to
like AX or something,
or trying to go to LA for
for the... (crosstalk)
- But it was just like every single time.
- You just run the risk of
you know dying of starvation,
- Every single time I was on the plane,
I was fucking hungry.
- Just eat a shit ton before you get on,
- Yeah.
- Bring a ton of snacks
and you'll be good.
- You just have to fast on air.
- The first time I didn't know.
I didn't know that,
'cause I saw that you
could pay for a meal.
But I was like,
oh, they'll give you like
a snack or something.
Nothing. You don't get anything.
You get nothing.
- Would you like this granola bar for $6.
(chuckling)
- And like these chairs,
I don't know how they,
it's like they've engineered these chairs,
to be fucking god awful.
Like, at least other airlines,
have semi competent chairs,
but for some reason on Norwegian airlines,
they fucking handcrafted this shit,
to be disgusting and painful.
And if you get in the
middle row of the four,
it's like just give up
on being happy in life,
for the next 12 hours.
And one time I went on it,
And there's, I was on the end,
the aisle seat, of the three.
Okay, well, it's not
the middle of the four.
- Yeah.
- So I'm happy.
And this couple were like
making out next to me.
I swear they were fingering each other.
Because I was like, this is disgusting.
I wanna die, please, please.
And no amount of like,
don't look at the side,
could like focus me on
Game of Thrones Season Four
or the fuck I was watching.
I was like, please, please, please.
- Yeah, because it's
like this the one time
you curse that you have
a periphery, right?
(Joey chuckling)
- Because the one every time,
I would take my headphones
off for a second,
I could hear like (mimicking)
- Oh my God.
- Oh God.
- Why?
- Tell you what, if you're
gonna go on a budget airline,
just pay 300 bucks for a good pair
of noise canceling headphones.
(Joey chuckling)
Honestly, like, that's the
best advice I can give you.
Don't cheap out on them.
- Jesus Christ.
- I don't know what it is about
the airplane design of
seats, that are just like,
ergonomically designed to be
the most uncomfortable thing
you've ever sat on.
- Did you see those standing
seats they were trying to make.
- No.
- What
- It's like to fit more people in,
they're trying to make
standing seats for airlines.
So that like they can fit more people,
its just basically like this,
- At this point,
what's the difference between
that and just being cattle?
You know what I mean?
(Joey chuckling)
Like, we're just we
literally being herded in.
- Obviously it was the budget
airlines trying to do this.
(Joey chuckling)
- It's like fucking sardines.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause they were like,
we can fit 20% more
passengers in the economy,
if we do this.
- But no one wants that.
- Yeah.
- No passenger wants that.
- 'Cause their argument, was
that if it's a two hour flight,
you can stand for two hours?
- No, no, I don't want to.
- No, no, no, it's terrible.
It's fucking awful.
- What's that?
- I don't mind a one hour
flight, I'm like, whatever.
But like when it's 12 hours,
sometimes I like bad seat.
- Even a prison transport
system has seats guys, come on.
(Joey chuckling)
- They do.
- Even a prison bus you
can sit down, right?
(Joey and Garnt chuckling)
Come on now.
- Yeah, it's sad man.
- Yeah.
- But the point was, is
that now that I'm older,
I'm grateful that my
parents took me on vacation.
But when I was a kid I fucking hated it.
- Also now I'm older, I'm
glad I have disposable income.
- Yeah.
- Back to the thinking about
to the broke uni student days.
You know what I mean?
Going back to Christmas?
Did you ever have like
any Christmas movies
or like stuff that you'd watch?
- I never got the concept
of Christmas movies
or like holiday movies.
I don't know, like my dad is
like such a fucking film snob.
- I hated it.
- But the moment he hears
the word Christmas movies,
he's like, poof.
Get a shit away from me.
- I had relationships where
they would wanna watch,
fucking around that time,
they would just be obsessed with watching
the same fucking movies and I'm like,
"I don't wanna watch for the 50th time."
- I'm currently in that
relationship right now.
(Joey chuckling)
- Oh, fucking man.
I'm like, you know what?
"Disney movies are fine,
but can we know not
watch just Disney movies?
Can we just watch something else?
- Oh, I'd rather that,
than the shitty live
action Christmas movies.
- Oh, fuck.
- Like it's always,
they always have like
the same kind of titles.
It's always the same theme of like,
"Oh, it's a romantic comedy kind of,
but it's also wholesome."
And by the way, the entire
soundtrack to the movie,
is Christmas carols.
Have fun.
- Every relationship I've been in,
they're like, "Yeah,
I love this Christmas
movie and they put it on,
it's fucking Elf, it's always Elf."
(Joey chuckling)
- It's always Elf.
- It's always fucking elf.
- Elf is like the Christmas class.
- I was trying to...
- Its like The Office
for like white people
but on Christmas (indistinct)
- I was trying to
convince Aki that Die Hard
is a Christmas movie.
- It is.
- It is, a Christmas movie.
- She did not believe me.
She was like, "Die Hard
the fucking yappy KI1 "
Yes the Ep KI1 that is a Christmas.
- There are two things that I know
that I will probably not
get on with the person
that if that if they say like
if they love Disney movies
more than like a healthy amount,
or if they want a horse.
Those are the two.
(Joey chuckles)
The two ways I know I'm probably
not gonna get on with them.
Some slides.
- What is it? What is
it about horse speeding?
- Everyone his haul skills are crazy man.
- Because they they're
gonna love the horse.
Especially being a relationship with one.
They're gonna love the horse
more than they ever love you.
Yeah, and that's just like,
that's a fact. That is 100%
- Horse skills are just the
equivalent of car dudes.
(Joey chuckles)
You know what I mean?
- It's dudes with a Honda
Civics in the profile picture.
- No offense, Alexi, but...
(all laughing)
But like, I don't know,
I've never, at least with
us like we never got like,
especially with like
Halloween movies as well.
It's like Halloween
movies, Christmas movies.
Are there even Easter
movies? Is that a thing?
- They try to make that.
- Is that a genre?
(crosstalk)
- That shouldn't be a
genre of Easter movies.
- [Meilyne] Passion of the Christ.
[All] The passion of Christ.
(indistinct)
- Passion of the crisis at least a movie.
Good old fun.
- One time my best mate, his
dad for his like 14th birthday
got in fucking Bruno on DVD.
(Joey chuckles)
He had no idea what it was.
But his joke was like,
I think you're gay son.
So his Bruno.
- What?
- No joke. I remember I went to his house,
(crosstalk)
What the fuck happens in this family?
We watched fucking Bruno
like 15 at his house.
And I mean so confused
with some other things.
- That's just like the
equivalent just like,
here you go."Why are you gay?"
- Why are you gay?
- You are gay.
- Here's Bruno, he was that
one kid where his parents
just didn't seem to give a fuck.
- Yeah.
- Like, yeah, sure you can watch porn.
Where are you two heading?
- All right, whatever.
We'll get to it eventually.
All right, just just get a
head start, you'll be good.
- So fucking weird, so weird.
- Like, I don't understand
watching some of the Christmas movies.
But I do like the feeling
of just getting together
and watching a movie.
Like, it doesn't necessarily
have to be a Christmas right?
- That's what I understand.
- I like watching like family movies,
especially on Christmas.
- My parents just have
shit tastes and movies.
- What? Wait, what's the
definition of a family movie?
Like a rom com? Or?
- I don't know.
I mean, I showed my
parents like Wolf children
with the family.
- That was like a very nice,
it was it was nice family bonding.
- I can not get my parents
to watch anything animated.
There like," Cartoons, no, no, no."
- Oh, no this was something I had to like,
slowly slip in the idea for years.
This is like this was like inception.
You know, for years, I would be like...
- Plant like seed.
- Yeah you don't just like rock up
and Christmas and be like,
"Mom, Dad, I want to show you
some animated titties."
No, you gotta like plant
the seed to be like,
"Yo, there's this."
- Like, I could not get my parents to like
no matter what I do, they would refuse.
- Oh yeah, my dad was like
fucking strict about his movies.
'Cause again, he's a fucking film snob.
So he's like, "The only
anime movies that I will like
and enjoy is Akira and Wicked City."
"If it doesn't have
animated, I ain't interested.
(Garnt and Joey chuckle)
- I think to people in the UK,
especially around my parents age,
to them anything animated
equals for children.
- Right? We should show them Wicked city.
(chuckles)
- I'm sure if I did...
(crosstalk)
- My dad like Ninja Scroll as well.
- Oh damn.
- Yeah.
- Your dad has taste, man.
But those are the only three movies,
it's like, "Is it violent,
does have titties in it?
(Garnt chuckles)
I'll watch it.
- Hell ya.
- So there's no way...
- Already a Christmas
movie, though, is it?
- No, I don't expect my dad to be like,
"Hey, son, Merry Christmas.
Let's watch Wicked City."
Like, I don't know.
Like, I never got the
idea of holiday movies.
I just never really saw the point.
Because, again, for us,
like Christmas was like,
a time to like celebrate with like family.
- I mean, like do believe in the so called
like Christmas spirits
and everything like that?
- What do you think I'm?
Do you think...
- Well I don't know, because
like, It's different now.
But the only the only
thing that's different now
really is being a YouTuber.
'Cause like my like my entire life,
up until I became a YouTuber,
Christmas was this like special holiday.
'Cause it was a holiday.
Like, especially if you're in
like an office job as well.
It was the biggest holiday of the year.
- Yeah.
- And so I don't know it was just like it.
I feel like I got programmed into thinking
that this was like a
just a special holiday.
And even if I wasn't my family,
you know, something like
watching Christmas anime for me,
like watching like some of
my favorite Christmas anime,
like The Disappearance of Haruhi.
He was just like that.
That's something I could never
get bored of watching them.
- Yeah, me too.
- It's a Christmas Day.
(Joey chuckling)
I know you love (crosstalk)
Like, I don't give a shit
about most Christmas movies.
But give me that Christmas anime man.
- Like I don't know.
I never I never chopped
up. I never thought.
Oh...
(crosstalk)
- I suppose it's weird for you.
Because you grew up in a country
where sunny and Christmas,
you know?
- Yeah.
- Every Christmas movie...
- There's no there's no concept of like,
grabbing a blanket and
cuddling up on the couch
to watch a Christmas movie.
- Yeah.
- Because you'd be sweating. (crosstalk)
- Always fucking cold in the UK.
So it's like, yeah.
- For us, It's like, "Oh, Merry Christmas,
let's turn it on the cricket."
(laughing)
that was in for us.
- I mean, I think that as I get older,
I think I appreciate the idea of it more,
which is just spending time with families.
My little brother lives with my parents
and my older brother
doesn't live too far away.
- Right?
- So it's not often to go visit him.
But for me it's, 'cause
I haven't seen them
in over like a year I guess,
when I moved to Japan.
And originally they were like,
"You want to come back
for Christmas Kotah?
Like the first Christmas
was like three months
after I moved here.
"Like No, I just got here."
(Joey chuckles)
I'm not coming back, fuck that,
I'll come next Christmas."
- I'm gonna celebrate
Christmas with the boys.
- I'll come next Christmas
site, that never happened.
(all laughing)
- Yeah, my family and like
over a year and a half now.
- Yeah.
- Is that weird, I don't know.
- No, it's weird.
- I mean, it's weird.
And I'm sure you would have seen them.
- Oh, I would have normally,
yeah, definitely seen them.
- Oh, yeah.
- We would not be here right
now if the regular Corona.
- Yeah.
- Exactly.
- Probably if it would be back but that's
how it is unfortunately.
And I guess as I get older,
it's made me appreciate that
what it is it's an excuse
to go see my family then come off.
- I don't know. Like I remember.
Like when as as a kid
and as a young adult,
I'm just like,
"Who gives a shit about tradition."
- I'm too cool.
- Who really gives about-
- Fuck the system.
- Who really gives about tradition and all
this stuff but like growing
older, I'm just like,
"There is something a bit special
about keeping family traditions
and doing something special and like,
it's, the whole Christmas bear thing
is like cheesy and shit like that.
But I will say like,
doing something special that
you do every year on Christmas
that reminds you of how you were as a kid
and stuff that your parents
parents like bestowed upon you
and everything is like,
there's something special about that.
- [Connor] Yeah.
- You appreciate, I appreciate them all.
Like those like I really liked as a kid,
didn't get as a teenager
and a young adult.
I'm like, more I've grown
older the more I'm like
"Yeah, that's a special thing."
- Yeah, I also wanna just
keep in touch with my parents,
obviously and just see
them as much as I can.
'Cause I just thought about I was like,
"Fuck, my little kid's
gonna be a little shit
if its raised by me."
- Yeah.
- Like, he's gonna
fucking, he's gonna fuck
off the moment he can.
I better instill some values
in him to come back and say hi.
(both laughing)
But I'm an old fuck.
- "Fuck my dad, you did the same thing."
It's like no.
'Cause I mean like, as a kid,
the highlight of Christmas was
the fucking presence, right?
As you grow older presence
become like a non factor now.
Is when you can just, when
you have a disposable income,
- Like, alright, give me the
presence. Give me a drink.
- Yeah, because my
parents now, they're like,
"What do I get you Connor?"
Because you know, you
buy everything you want.
And I'm like, "Well,
I don't know actually,
I don't know. Think of something."
(laughing)
- "Yeah, money can I ask money?"
- So now our presence are
just like a non factor,
you you gotta have
something to look forward
to for the Christmas holidays, right?
- That's true.
- Spending time with the family.
- Spending time with
the family, or the boys.
Yeah, to explain what we
did last year in Christmas.
We just stayed up to like 3
a.m watching Super Monkey Ball,
speed runs and it was fucking amazing.
- That was good.
- Amazing.
- Don't belittle it.
- Can we start tradition.
(Connor laughing)
(crosstalk)
Obviously I could start that
fucking tradition, right?
You don't know the magic of
Super Monkey Ball speed runs
until you watch one.
- Dude that like, especially
when you're drunk as well.
Like insane. Like it just defies gravity.
And like, just enjoyment,
but it's really entertaining.
It was super entertaining.
- But we also watch Die
Hard right before that.
- We did watch, or we did
we actually did watch.
- Oh we did watch a Christmas movie.
- Yeah, because that was
when I was still naive
and thinking like Die Hard
isn't a Christmas movie.
And then you guys will
like, "No, no trust us."
- You can still eating the hotpot, right.
While I play it, that's right.
- Yeah.
- And then we're like, let's
watch a Christmas movie.
Die Hard.
And then we want something
like, "Well, you know what?
It's I stand corrected.
This is a Christmas movie."
- It is Christmas movie.
- You know before fucking Bruce Willis
just gave up on acting.
You've seen his recent films.
- No.
- Oh, fucking how that awful.
- Really.
- He refuses to like do anything
and he's a double doing everything.
- Jesus.
- You should watch some of them.
- Do you watch, what
is it called Hard kill?
Watch that movie.
- Hard kill?
- Hard Kill, watch that movie.
- Sounds like a fucking Die Hard.
- I fucking watched it
and it's oh my fucking god.
- 'Cause I watched
Looper, and I was like...
- I just realized the
absurdity of that name.
- He does...
- [Joey and Garnt] Hard Kill.
- He does like he just
like six movies a year
and there all like straight to DVD.
- That's like a Kadima
character, you know what I mean?
- Seriously, watch these dudes.
- Its like a metal geek (indistinct)
- In some of these scenes
he's given so little fuck
about trying, that like it's
just a dubbed over actor.
- It's just like...
- He's so lazy dude.
- Let's take two edgy words
and smash them together.
Like hot death knife, hot kill.
(Joey chuckles)
- Please okay, this Christmas,
we're watching Hard Kill.
And you could see how fucking
awful Bruce Willis is.
- I gonna say I gotta say.
- He's fucking terrible.
'Cause I think the last Bruce Willis film
I watched was Looper.
And even then it was like,
your not even trying.
- You've given up, you don't give a fuck.
- This guy's made his cash
already, like he's just
(crosstalk)
- You have made so much
money just fucking stop.
- Yeah.
That one Joseph Gordon
Levitt is like acting,
Bruce Willis which is like,
"You can you can carry this one."
- (crosstalk) And it's
just like Bruce Willis.
He stands up to the set
and apparently like all the things he does
is like he agrees to do like
three days of shooting right?
And that's it like no more, no retakes.
- Really.
- And hot, anything that
physically doesn't require him
is a body double.
So even if it's like getting on his knees.
- Yeah.
- Like don't you get a body (indistinct).
(Joey chuckles)
Because he's too lazy to do it.
- Oh, my God.
I did watch a, I don't know
when it was pretty recent.
But why it did like a Bruce Willis
answers like most googled questions.
- He doesn't give a fuck.
- It was one of the most boring
wide videos I'd ever seen.
Because he just he was
monotone the entire time.
- At least like Harrison
Ford, when you can tell
that he respects the
movie and the director
tries like in Blade Runner, the new one.
He was fucking amazing.
- Yeah.
- But when he's in interviews,
he's like, "I don't fucking give a shit."
Bruce Willis is always like that.
Like nothing makes Bruce Willis care.
Like he literally is like
the angriest oldest con,
in all of these interviews
like, you can tell he's like,
"Yeah whatever, I've made my money.
I just set up I just tuned up
and said words, it's acting."
Like all right Bruce Willis fucking out.
- God could you imagine if
YouTubers get to that point?
(crosstalk)
- Yeah, I didn't know
I didn't want to say,
but some of us are already there.
Not us.
I mean, some YouTubers already there.
- God, I just couldn't
imagine just still doing it
when I hate this.
I'm not like that.
- Like especially if you've already
made your fucking fortunate and name.
- At that point, you just
doing it stay relevant.
- Yeah, right.
(crosstalk)
- Yeah, but like the thing
is like you don't have
to stay relevant.
If you don't Like at the
point of like Bruce Willis,
like everyone knows your fucking name
and what you look like.
- That's why like, no
one watches action movies
and like that has like a big name to it.
That's why they get
him, because they can...
He just makes it a lot of bank,
his name has a lot of
poll for action movies,
doesn't give a fuck.
- That's true.
- I mean are action movies
even like a big thing nowadays?
- Yeah, 'cause John wick is...
(crosstalk)
- I was gonna say like,
aside from john wick.
- But that's the thing right
if you can bring it back
and you can do it well,
with the right actors,
like it'll be huge.
- Like you're talking about
like, ones that aren't falling
under like a notable IP.
- Yeah.
- But John Wick why
can't kill (indistinct)
- Like John Wick, wasn't a notable IP,
until (indistinct) notable IP.
- But when did John
Wick one... (crosstalk)
- Hard Kill to me sounds
like one of those titles
where like say when I when
I was in Thailand, right?
That I would I would always have this,
I would always go to like
in like Southeast Asia.
There's always these stores
that you can buy like,
pirated pirated DVD.
- Yeah.
- And you'd go through like
you flick through the covers,
and you'd see these like
the most random movies
of these like A-list actors,
but you'd never heard
of the film before.
- Yeah
- That's Hard Kill.
(Joey chuckles)
- That is also all of Bruce
Willis' recent filmography.
Its old movies like, how is this man doing
eight movies a year?
How does that happen? How
do you have time for that?
- I kind of want to just
like go through his IMDb,
just to see the title.
- And it's like, that I think
that's the reason why and
like, imagine at the time,
people would probably didn't give a fuck
about action movies until
like Terminator came out.
And probably at that time, you're like,
this is this is crazy.
What the fuck like, because I mean,
that's not James Cameron
directing it, which...
- Like 80's was like a
fucking golden period
for action movie.
- Right.
- Because it was like the Schwarzenegger,
who's the other one?
- Stallone.
- Stallone, right?
- Claude Van Damme.
- Yeah, I mean I could, really
easily re watch, like so many
of their action movies.
- And that's also when like martial arts
when results I was drawn
to like, kind of...
- Yeah, 'cause I feel
like before John Wick,
there was this huge
period, where action movies
were just not putting
in the numbers any more.
- I'm so reading these fucking titles,
I've never had any of
these fucking movies.
- Yeah, because they're
all straight to DVD.
- So we have 2017, First kill.
(Garnt laughing)
Acts of Violence, Death Wish, Airstrike,
10 Minutes Gone.
Trauma center, Survive The Night.
I don't know any of it.
By the way, all of
those are direct to DVD.
- Yeah. All of them.
- Sounds like a satire of
themselves at that point.
- No one wants to hire
him, because why would you,
he's just gonna turn
up and fucking be lazy.
- And this five movies right
now that has been announced
with Humana that is like to be announced.
Midnight in the Switch Grass.
- Well we got...
- Cosmic Scene.
- All right, we're watching
one of these on Christmas man,
I got it because they fucking
awesome, we're gonna watch it.
He's given up dude. It's terrible.
- Oh my God that's really bad.
- Stop making films, like why?
- Its really sad.
- We'll watch one of these on Christmas
and tell you how it is next time.
- Why?
- Oh, my God!
- Do you boys have any
plans this Christmas, like?
- I mean...
- I'm curious to see what
this Christmas will be like
in the current world situation.
- [Joey] Sure.
- It's probably gonna be the
most depressing Christmas
of all time.
- Because Christmas in Japan
is like it's a bit weird,
because...
- Do you wanna explain what
Christmas in Japan is like?
- Yeah, so essentially...
- Be it by KFC
- Christmas in Japan is
sponsored by KFC, basically,
it's like KFC, is the go to place.
- How did that start?
- Japan, okay, it's because I did a video
on this a few years ago,
but basically the theory
is that Colonel Sanders
right, looks like Santa.
([Garnt Chuckles)
That's the theory.
Because think about it, right?
Think about it. Christmas colors.
What are the Christmas colors red?
- Yeah.
What does Colonel Sanders
dressed up in red, right?
- Doesn't he, white it is I thought.
- But the KFC color has red
on it and then Colonel Sanders
is an old guy with a white beard.
Kind of looks like Santa right?
- And I bet if you trace that back,
it's like the most five head KFC employee
like working in the marketing team.
- Yeah that's basically it,
it was a marketing ploy by KFC
to be (crosstalk) basically
they were like well,
the Christmas dinner
overseas and in the West
they have chicken.
- Yeah.
- They have roast chicken.
(Garnt laughs)
Fried chicken is kind
of the same thing right?
Like still chicken.
- Yeah.
Why don't we try this,
Let's try one (crosstalk)
We're gonna try and sell this,
and it just fucking exploded
because you can't get a
roast chicken in Japan,
other than KFC.
- Outside of some convenience,
I saw this there'll be an employee dressed
in a Santa outfit, with a
fried chicken. (crosstalk)
- They sell like cakes, right?
- This is fucking weird,
what am I looking at?
- It's bizarre.
- I'm looking at an Asian man
dressed in a Santa costume,
selling me fried chicken
in the name of Christmas.
I'm like what the fuck?
- But it's also weird as well because,
like normally like everywhere
else in the West, right?
Christmas is like a family thing.
You gather like mom, dad, grandparents.
Here in Japan it's like a beta balance.
- It's a you go on dates.
Yeah, you all should go to the prom.
That's that's Christmas eve.
- But that part I understand
because literally a week later
its New Year's Eve right?
And New Year's Eve is like
a super Buddhist family thing in Japan.
- Yeah.
- So it makes sense...
- The opposite of what it
is in Western cultures.
(laughing)
- In Wester culture like
its like oh, New Year's Eve.
(crosstalk)
See next year parents.
Yeah. So I don't know.
I just, I personally have
I mean, well, this year,
I plan to go up north to go see Chris.
And we're gonna we're gonna go
to Nazi Spies and have KFC for Christmas.
- For Christmas.
(Garnt chuckling)
- Yeah, that's the plan. That's the plan.
And I'm like, man, first time ever.
I've been lucky five years.
First Year, I'm gonna have
the true Japanese Christmas experience
of eating KFC.
I'll let you boys know how
depressing it actually is.
But...
- Because it's not like I
remember before coming to Japan,
I'd heard so many rumors
about Japanese KFC
being the best KFC in the world.
You ain't tried KFC until
you had Japanese KFC
and then I came here and then I hate it
and then it was just KFC.
- Yeah.
- The UK one was better even.
- I thought the UK we have a better menu.
- It is the most meat KFC I've ever had.
- Yeah.
- And I love the burgers,
the chicken sandwiches
that you get in KFC.
That's fucking amazing.
- Oh yeah, they're fucking awesome.
- In the UK, they're so good as well.
- Honestly, I don't know
what it is about UK, KFC.
- Is good.
- I mean...
- I feel though you guys
have kind of perfected
like fast food chicken with Nando's right?
- I mean, that's like
South African though.
- Yeah, definitely.
- But we just I think every
single fast food chain
in the UK has like fried chicken options
as a not on its own.
Like McDonald's I think
some of those popular
stuff they sell in the UK is like,
just like a chicken selects
and also like the wrapped chicken.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's fucking amazing,
that's the best thing I get.
- That sounds good.
And every like dirty kebab
still has like the fried
chicken option as well.
So this is fried chicken everywhere.
But like, yeah, I don't know.
Because British is the best KFC,
Japan is like somewhere in the middle
and then America is like(crosstalk)
- Do I want to feel like shit? KFC it is.
- Yeah, I don't know
why, like American KFC
just stopped trying 'cause
there's not like America
doesn't have bad fried chicken options.
It's just one of the like,
some of the biggest chains
are just the worst in America.
And I don't understand why.
- I remember I was drunk one time
someone gave me a KFC chicken.
- In America?
- Yeah.
- Even drunk me was like this is violent.
(Joey chuckles)
And it's bad if I'm drunk me is like,
this is too much.
I draw the line at the amount of grease
that is on this thing.
- Yeah.
- Like the skin wasn't crispy.
It was moist from all the grease it had.
That's vile sorry we somehow turn
this all around a bashing America.
(Garnt and Joey chuckle)
I love America I do, I
just what's going on now?
- America can't do chicken correctly.
Case in point Chick-fil-A?
- Yeah, Chick-fil-A.
But like that's why I
don't understand why anyone
in America would eat KFC
when there's stuff like,
chick-fil-A or Popeye.
- I never see good reviews on
Google Maps or for like KFC.
It's always like two stars, and I'm like,
who's willingly going in here?
Stop giving them fucking
customers, just stop.
- Yeah.
- Because its Sunday, right
and chick-fil-A is closed.
- That's true, I mean, not not all parts
of America have Chick-fil-A apparently.
- Yeah, no, they don't do that.
- East Coast doesn't have
Chick-fil- A or something.
I don't know.
- There's like different chains,
different areas as well, I know.
But what I know is KFC is the worst
fried chicken I've ever had in America.
- Yeah, honestly, now I
feel like Christmas for me
is more of like, it's
Christmas when I spend it
with the people, right?
So it doesn't have to be on Christmas Day.
Around the time give or take
as I hang out with some friends.
- It could be like a week before.
- Get a few drinks.
- Just be like let's just
do an early Christmas.
- Strange a few gifts,
you know , its Christmas.
- I do want to do something on Christmas,
because this...
- I do.
- I find like Christmases
where I've done nothing before.
And it is a bit depressing when
you're just like by yourself
or they do nothing.
You go on your timeline,
you get into twitter
everyone's opening presents
with each other just like...
- But what if you haven't
like Christmas Day,
the next day with your friends?
It's like alright,
whatever, I'm getting it.
I think it's what's worse
is New Year's alone for some reason.
- I've had New Year's alone before
- Yes, say I have to, and for some reason,
It's more depressing than Christmas alone.
I don't know why.
- I spent New Year's,
one year in the worst
fucking way possible.
I think I was like 16
and I was working up at a
ski field the first time
I was working up at a ski field.
And we're in the middle of
Hokkaido in the mountains.
It's like fucking minus 30
degrees in a fucking Blizzard.
And of course, I'm working that day.
I'm outside in the fucking
Blizzard shoveling snow.
But on top of that, one of the hotels
had a blocked sewage system.
And I had to get in there
with a fucking shovel.
So imagine a 16 year old right?
In the middle of a fucking blizzard
in the mountains.
Literally shoveling
shit out of the ground.
- I like, "Happy New Year"
Like 11 p.m, yeah.
And literally the moment
we've uncovered the thing,
my boss was like, "Oh it's the next year."
- Yeah.
"Happy New Year."
- Did you unclog it?
Oh, yeah, we did.
- Nice.
- But also it was like, cool.
My first experience of
the New Year is the smell
of frozen shit.
- And it's only up from there, right?
- Yeah, I mean, well, sure.
It was a good year, but it wasn't.
It wasn't the greatest start of the year,
that's for sure.
- I feel like New Year's
like the biggest hoax
that everyone's put over the case.
- It's never as good as you want it to be.
- It's hyped up as the
biggest party of the year.
And nobody knows what they're doing
until the day before I swear
to fucking (indistinct)
(Joey chuckles)
- Everything's full. Like
you can't get in anywhere.
- Everywhere is overpriced.
Everywhere is full,
everyone's doing something
aside from you, for some reason,
even though you ask a week before,
"Hey, what are you doing with New Year's."
and they don't fucking know.
And yes somehow on New
Year's you're that one fucker
who just has nothing nothing planned.
- It's always the last
one like the last day
of the year,
you have the biggest FOMO of the year.
And you like (breathes heavily)
- It is always somehow always more often
than not doing nothing
like always being like,
fuck I missed out.
- Yeah.
- Like, you might as well rename
New Year's Eve FOMO party,
because that's what it is.
That's what New Year's Eve is.
Everyone goes out because
they're afraid of missing out
because I've spent New Year's alone before
and it is depressing.
- Its really depressing.
Yeah, it's it's really fucking depressing.
- Shout out to the people out
there who's gonna be alone.
- But like, at the same time,
some of my worst fucking nights have been
on New Year's Eve as well.
- Its never a good night.
It's always just so stressful
because you can never get
like a taxi either.
- Yeah.
- If you need to get back,
'cause everyone's getting
taxis (indistinct)
- It only took me one New Year's Eve
of going out to know that.
All right, next New Year's Eve from now on
is just house parties.
- The only people who
win Uber drivers, man.
They're the only ones
winning the New Year.
- True.
- Fuck, man. I got, New
Years is for the worst.
(Garnt and Joey chuckle)
Fuck, I just realized how
much I hate New Year's
Because I gotta do something.
I don't want to be sad.
- Like yo, either sad or
you're having a shit night,
or you're broke.
There's no...
- There's no perfect New Year's Eve.
- Yeah, sure.
- My God, I fucking hate New Year's.
(laughing)
- Do you guys have any
plans for this New Year?
- [Both] No.
- I'll figure that out
when it comes to it.
- Yeah, you'll figure that out before...
- We just said we don't, we
nobody knows what they're doing
until like the day fucking before.
- Yeah, because everyone's
they always do this thing
for New Year's right?
Where everyone's like,
"We could go here," like
everyone is always like,
(crosstalk)
Everyone's throw suggestions
on New Year's but no one wants
to commit to it.
Because you don't want to be the asshole
who took them to a place that's full.
- Right.
- And then it's like, "Well, then what?."
Like we're in the...
- Because no one wants to
commit 'cause everyone knows,
"Okay, this place is gonna
be overpriced and full"
Let's leave this until
like the last moment,
because the thing is,
there is no good place
for New Year's Eve.
But you have to go to a place, right?
- Like your your maybe
your friend can get you
into somewhere and then you can only get
like half your friends in.
- Right.
- And then it's like, well,
what the fuck is happening?
Do we just leave half off friends
and tell them to go fuck themselves?
- Yeah, but I'm like the best
New Year's Eve party would
probably be a house party.
But like no one wants to host
a New Year's Eve house party.
Right?
- Sure, it's always like a voting ballot,
but you just don't want that.
- And even then it's like,
"Do I really like everyone in this party?"
Like see other people?
- Because like as like a teenager,
if you're hosting a New
Year's Eve house party,
that house is getting trashed?
- Oh, yeah.
- You knew it was getting trashed.
And no matter how small
you wanted it to be?
It was never going to be small.
Because it's a New Year's Eve party.
- Yeah, but yeah, because
you don't want it to be like
because it's somehow like,
reverse like depressing when
it's like, three people.
- Too small and it's depressing.
- Yeah.
- But like I'd like I swear like,
as a teenager you'd have like
fucking sniffer dogs trying
to sniff out house
bodies man you just like,
"Where can we go boys? Where can we go?"
- "I've heard in the grapevine that there
is a house party somewhere around here."
- That one mate who knows
someone who'd known someone
who's less who'd heard about,
a house party happening (crosstalk)
- Not proud of it definitely
spent a New Year's just going
to house parties that like we just full
and then not being able
to get into any of them.
- Right.
- And then I was like, "Guess
we're just going to Tesco
and getting a few beers
and just sitting outside."
- I've had some of the most
like depressing New Year's Eve
go it's like trying to like
house haunt a house party.
- Right.
- And we just be literally be like, six.
I'm like the time we
would stop and be like,
"Okay, who's heard some rumors?"
"We're gonna follow up a rumor.
Phone up all your contacts."
(crosstalk)
- Get the clues, right now.
- Call all the favors you know like...
Because no one wants to be
that guy who invites everyone
to the house.
- [Joey] Right.
- But sometimes, you know
I mate he owes you a favor
who's out the house party.
Your like, "Just give me
the general directions."
(crosstalk)
- When you've had a friend
who just got blackout drunk
before midnight, that's like fuck.
- I've been there before.
- Like, gonna fucking take
care of that man, fuck.
- I've had some New Year's where I've like
passed out like 10 p.m.
(all chuckling)
- See you next year lads.
(all laughing)
Those are the days.
Man what a depressing
message to end this year.
(chuckling)
- Hey man if you're depressed
on New Year's don't worry
everyone is.
- Everyone is.
- We've all been there.
- But who isn't depressed?
Our wonderful patreons.
- Oh my God look them.
- Look at these amazing patreons.
- Thank you so much patreons.
- You make me not depressed.
(Joey chuckling)
- You gave us the real Christmas presents.
- Your patronage has made us happy.
- Shout out to all the fucking degenerates
who just like, we are filming
this just after the massive
fucking burst for my Hentai episode.
What the fuck?
Why the fuck did you guys do?
- That was the definition
of stonks, right?
(Garnt chuckles)
- That was stonks...
- People like porn men, people like porn.
- Stonks brain. Oh, my God.
- I didn't realize throughout
my entire five year
YouTube career, like that all
I needed to do was to talk
about animated porn.
Why didn't you tell me this
at the beginning of my career.
- With the amount of
hentai videos I've made.
I am actually like that jump
actually made me depressed.
Like I could have cashed in
on that man, but I didn't.
But yeah, if you'd like
to join us on the patreon
with lovely rewards and whatnot,
then you can go over to
patreon.com/TrashTaste links
in the description.
Also check out our Twitter
and Subreddit as well.
Send us all your Christmas
and New Year's memes.
- [Garnt] Yes.
- [Connor] Fantastic.
- And share us your best gifts.
(crosstalk)
- Let us know in the comments.
- We don't know what we're
getting for Christmas here.
(Joey chuckles)
- Shout out to patreon.
- Shout out to patreons,
hope you've had a very Merry
Christmas or like, you have
to say Happy Holidays now.
- Happy holidays fucking...
- Who cares.
- Like Merry Christmas, hope you guys
because it's Boxing Day Merry Christmas
and we hope you have a
non depressing New Year's
(all chuckling)
- Yeah, this is the last episode of 2020.
And next time we see
you guys will be 2021,
hopefully won't suck as much as 2020.
- It probably will.
- We've set the bar so
low, I don't want to say,
can't get any worse, right guys?
(Joey chuckling)
- Well, at least trash
tasted good this year, boys.
- Exactly.
- [Garnt] Yeah.
Thank you for joining
us on TrashTaste 2020,
see you next year.
- Happy holidays.
- [Garnt and Joey] Happy holidays.
- See you next year.
- Bye.
- [Garnt] Bye.
(upbeat music)